autodesk revit is a building information
modeling software for architects
engineers and designers in this
university course you will learn how to
use revit for 3d modeling and design
so this one is going to be focused on
giving you the basis
for working in revit
so i'm going to
probably record three videos three
tutorial videos just showing from start
to finish how to produce a very very
simple
very very basic project in revit so
the course itself has a website of
course and
as
long students you already have seen the
course those of you who are not fluent
students can also kind of jump in
jump into the website by just
writing down this this address here
and in the course we have a lot of
information here but that's not not
not that important what's important is
um
where is it oh my god i will need to
re-format
this uh what's important is what kind of
a
client you're going to choose your your
fictional client for for the project and
also uh this
supplementary material right so we will
not be starting from scratch we will be
using a 3d model that i've made
um to get you guys started to just have
some sort of a environment ready
for us to model in
so
there are these two
links here site 3d model and sat format
and site 3d model in rhino 5 format the
reason i use rhino5 is because
i just make sure that everyone can
follow along you know with the older
version of rhino
so
i have already kind of made it and
downloaded it and so on once you do that
and you open it up you will see
[Music]
this 3d model right here
so the task of the course is going to be
um to
3d model out some sort of a building
in between these two
so it's you know it's it's kind of a
challenge it's it's quite a narrow one
and these are called narrow buildings
for a reason right
um
right so
we will
let's just take a
closer look at it in arctic view
there's nothing fancy i believe i just
extracted some dwg file from uh lund
city
um
and just modeled out a few few buildings
from that dwg file
so
we are now looking in rhino but this
course is about revit so let's stop
looking at it in rhino and rather let's
look at it in revit so in revit
once you open up revit you will be
presented with this
window here
um and
basically it's asking you to create a
new file right to start working so we
will do exactly that i will click on
new models new
and here it's going to ask me what kind
of
template do i want to use and it
asks you whether or not you would like
to use imperial units or metric units
so i will be using metric of course
in sweden we do use metric system
um
and if you don't see it here you can
always click on browse
and then expand the top
bar here
go back to
uh templates
so 1 1 4 up or
so to say
and here you will see
english or
we just
ah let's go for
english
default metric we can use that one
so it's it's either one
you matter
i'll use default metric that that seems
fine i'll just hit open
yep sure hit ok
and it's going to load up a new file for
us
once that's done i will immediately save
it
just so that auto saving kicks in and if
it crashes or anything like that i don't
lose a lot of information so i'll go to
file save as
oh can i just save i'll save yeah i can
just save well
here i'll just save it to my desktop
because i don't have a folder for it
ada15
tutorials
sure
hit save
that's it so so you're done with that
right so let's start with me showing you
the user interface or either kind of
quickly going through the user interface
so here in in the right and the top we
have a few mostly used
shortcut buttons
such as open file save file plot undo
redo
check dimension and so on right
so those are kind of handy
but i don't tend to use them that often
if i need to save something i'll just
click on this file tab and just choose
to save here i don't know why but
that's just how i do it
and here right below those shortcut
buttons you have your tabs your tabs
where
all of the tools
in revit are located
so
i already showed you the
file tab well it's not really a tab but
the file button here
for opening a new file
or creating a new file opening up a file
existing one saving all all of that good
stuff
um so that's not interesting but what's
interesting is these
tool tabs here we have architecture we
will be using quite a bit of it of the
tools in architecture tab of course
uh this is like the main one
structure tab
uh we will almost
not be wait let me see no we will not be
using anything from the structure tab
even though it's it's super for for
engineering purposes but since this is
just uh
like a proposal level
entry-level project that we're doing
we don't really need needed
then we have steel precast and systems
tabs all of these are engineering
related we don't care
about them insert tab basically lets you
import
or insert stuff that's not native to
revit such as dwg files and
and whatnot images
we will be using a little bit of it
annotate tab
um actually quite useful i'm not sure if
we will be using it though
maybe text we will see but annotate is
basically dimensions text
tags
symbols all of that good stuff is in the
annotate tab
analyze we will not be using that
messing inside
um
[Music]
in this case uh for this particular
course i'm not sure if we are going to
be using it
but in aada
20 in the next course
i believe we will
so you'll need to wait for that
collaborate basically it helps you
if you're working in a team uh tools
here
help you
collaborate with other people working on
the same project
quite a strong tool
uh but given the situation of of code
and not not being able
all of us not being able to be in the
school
uh we will be skipping skipping this
tab right here
view tab quite
um yeah we will be using it quite quite
a bit
um basically just is used to make
sections to extract 3d views elevations
and also changing the the graphics of
the drawings themselves
i will be revisiting it quite a bit
manage add-ins and modify
um these three tabs we will not be using
that much well modify tab you will
notice when we will be
[Music]
double clicking on or changing some sort
of geometry modify tab will
automatically open up with additional
uh tools
uh that that can be used for that
precise geometry for instance if you
create a floor slab and you want to edit
the boundary of the of the floor slab
uh then you
um
i believe double click it or click on
edit i don't remember
i'm not a revit user by the way
um but it will open up the modify tab
where you will have
additional tools available for you to
modify the boundary of the floor
you'll see that in action in just a
second okay so that's all about the tabs
then here on the left hand side you have
the the properties
so these are the properties of every
piece of geometry that there is if that
you have selected right
if you don't have anything selected that
means
the the properties will show you
uh the settings for the view itself
and in this case we are in level one
so we're looking at the top of for for
level one that's that's our view and
it's basically the properties or the
settings for that particular view
uh once we have some geometry in here i
will talk about the properties a little
bit more
uh then we have our
project browser
which is basically all of our views all
of our floor plans and so on are going
to be located here so right now since we
loaded up the
default
template
uh it already has a few
a few views set up for us and actually
it has too many
so we don't need that many views right
now
and what i'm going to do is i will
probably get rid of
yeah let's get rid of them so for
instance ceiling plants we don't really
need any ceiling plants whatsoever so
i'll just
single click to select level one and hit
delete
single click to select just make sure
that you are deleting ceiling plants not
the floor plans right i select level two
delete don't need those
as for elevations we will be creating
our own elevations so we don't really
need that as well so i'll delete the
east north south
west elevations as well
all right so now
we we only see level one level two and
site actually level two
i'll get rid of that as well
okay so now we only have level one and
site uh two two plants
i want to import
my
geometry into the model right
sorry my geometry by my geometry i mean
the surrounding environment into this
revit model
to actually have something to work work
with
to do that i will go to
uh insert
i'll choose to import
cad
right
import cad
which is going to basically ask me
where's the model and what kind of
format
should i use so as you can see here it
does accept rhino files which is great
we we can use the the rhino file aeda15
site
that's fine
or
if that
gives you an error sometimes it does
just to be safe
uh there's also an option to import sat
file acis sat file
um so that sat file is also located
let me just
add right here
site 3d model in set format
so if rhino gives you problems importing
rhino gives you problems just import the
sat file uh i'll import the set file i
guess so i'll select that select the set
file that i have downloaded
um
blah blah blah
import as category
so that's an important one
basically in
revit
every piece of geometry belongs to a
geometry category right so revit needs
to to know what kind of geometry is it
is it a column is it a ceiling is it a
door
you know what what is it
so here uh
our site model is neither one of those
things right
so we will be importing it is
it as a generic model
so i'll hit on open
generic model is basically
yeah just anything
geometry that doesn't have a type
and it seems like it's import it has
been imported
good enough
seems like it's fine
okay so we have our geometry here
that's great
and we have these doodads
right here
which we don't really need so these are
leftovers from where we had the
elevations
elevation views these were markers for
elevation views i think i'll just delete
them
delete delete
so i'm just selecting them uh just click
delete
click delete if you don't have them
that's even better
okay so we have our top view of our
generic model
that's cool and all but we kind of want
to
uh also see it in 3d right
no just to
understand uh
how well did it import so to do that we
can go to view
and we can create view tab and we can
create 3d view
that's it
that's all we needed to do
um so
now on to how do we navigate in the
viewport in the 3d viewport in revit so
you do it by holding down the shift key
and clicking the scroll wheel
clicking and dragging the scroll wheel
you can rotate
if you just click and drag the scroll
wheel you pan
scroll wheel
right now there's not a lot of things
going on here nothing too fancy
um but that's fine
all right so we have our 3d model here
and let's start creating some or rather
preparing to create some
um
some geometries
so what i like doing is
oh by the way sorry every view that you
open will be
shown here in these tabs so you can
easily switch between them or you can
just double click on the
on the name of the view here level one
uh
so in revit you always work
not always but most of the time you work
in plan views like um what would be a
good example
like in sims
like in that video game sims
um
you kind of work in plan view and the 3d
view is just represent it it becomes
like a representation of that so all of
the drawing and
drawing of walls and whatnot is done in
plan view
so in level one
okay so let's start off by
actually
giving it a few axes
that's at least what i like to do in
this case it doesn't really make a lot
of sense but i still like to do it just
to keep it clean so i'll go to
architecture tab
and i'll choose grid here
grid
bam
and as you can see immediately once i
chose the grid option
it gives me
it it takes me to modify tab
where it basically asks us
how would you like to place the grid
where would you like to place the grid
axis
so i will do that
by just clicking on these endpoints and
the snapping is kind of kind of nice in
revit
so i'll click on one of the corners of
the surrounding buildings and i'll drag
out the grid
line here
that's our first grid line and i'll do
the same thing for the second one
from here
to here and align them perfect
so that's our
grid axis one and grid axis two
um i could do grid axis three and four
maybe we should
so grid axis three
um i wonder
should it should we do it here
or should we do it
here
let's do it here
so that's our grid axis three oh come on
there we go
and that's going to be our grid access
form
bam
done
once you've done that you just hit
escape
[Music]
that's all that's all
right so now i will just clean them up a
little bit
so i'll click on this uh arrow key here
or i believe i can just hit escape once
more
um and then it will automatically go to
my arrow key
or arrow
tool
i'll select let's say grid access three
and i'll add
this this markup three i will add it
to the other side as well right here
three
so let me do that again you select grid
access three and there's a tick mark box
on the other side
right which you tick and then it's
basically it understands that oh okay i
need to show
uh the grid axis
okay that's good
for grid access for we do the same thing
we find that tick box here sometimes
it's hard to see it
of course it starts auto saving
let's wait there we go
red x is four
then there same thing for axis one and
same thing for axis 2.
let me drag them out a little bit so
that it's
nice and tidy
there we go
up
there we go i might need to squish the
scooch
grid axis three and four closer uh to
the to the building but that's gonna be
done later
for now this is good enough um
so in architecture you don't really have
a grid axis going in both directions
being marked
in numbers so if in one direction grid
axes are marked in numbers one two three
four five and the other one they're
going to be marked in letters a b c d
blah blah blah
so here for grid access three
where it says name
let me do that again maybe it's a little
bit too fast i'll select grid axis 3 and
i'll say that no this is not 3 this is a
so i select it
once i selected the properties changes
and here where it says name i will just
change this to a
hit apply
very good
same thing for a grid access 4. instead
of 4 i change this to b
there we go
okay so now we are all set we are all
set to start uh start
making our
building
right so
before um
i wonder which which
yeah let's start with walls right
i think we should start with walls
um
so to to add a wall there is this wall
tool the
of course it's under architecture tab
wall
if i expand it i can see that there are
a few options here but for now we don't
care about those options we just care
about the regular wall tool right so i
will not be expanding that that tool
i'll click on the wall tool
and
before i start just going to town
drawing it i will
choose instead of having basic wall
generic 200 millimeters
i will choose
a thicker one actually the one that that
we should be using
is like
400 500 millimeters
but we don't have it in in this
drop down list
so i will probably just
just say yeah screw it let's do 300
millimeters
who cares
right but usually you when working in an
office you do have
a library that office itself has a
library of walls that
that office uses right
um and and then you can just choose from
from that library here it's just generic
stuff so
yeah sure we will just use generic stuff
so 300 millimeters it is
um i believe in
in sweden it's it's
right now the regulation is around
you can't get away with walls that are
thinner
than
around 500 millimeters
due to heat insulation being so so thick
but i might be wrong about that
at least at least in the baltic region
it's it's 500 millimeters
but 300 is fine here um okay so we have
our wall type then we have our location
line and also it's it's kind of
the
mostly used settings are kind of here
in the in the top row
uh where it basically asks for what kind
of height the wall should have
um
what's the location of the line so let
me explain how how that works so
to determine
height of the wall
let's do
unconnected
right
so it's it's height and it's unconnected
right
and the the unconnected height from
level one upwards
here is set to be eight hundred eight
thousand millimeters so eight meters
right
um
and so that's fine that's fine for us
right now because i'm just showing you
how it works
um
but the nice thing about it is that you
can have it connected to
the second floor right so if you change
the height of the second floor the
height of the wall will change as well i
will show that in just a second
uh for now let's have it unconnected
eight 000
location of the line center line
so if it's center line and i start
drawing a wall you can see that it draws
as if that that line through which i
draw the wall is right in the middle of
the wall so i don't really need that i
don't really want that
um i want the wall to go inwards here
right
so instead of a center line i will say
finish face exterior
right
and then i'll start start drawing the
wall as if it's
not as if but i will start drawing the
wall clockwise so
that the exterior is is is on the
outside
like that
like that
so i'm just kind of snapping it
that's it right we have we have our wall
if i check it in 3d
i kind of look at it
that's our wall that we just drew
and it's exactly eight meters high right
let me jump back to level one
you just uh see
a few more uh a few more settings that
that can be changed so
let me
delete that
all together
um grab the wall tool again
um
and and continue on with with the
with the settings so here we have a
chain chain is basically once you
finished drawing one segment of the wall
it will ask you to continue drawing the
other segment and then the other and
then the other right so it chains
segments of the wall
like a polyline it basically works like
a polyline rather than a line tool
offset is basically
let's say 250 ml offset from where we
draw
and that's
the bad offset
let's say offset minus 250 to the other
side
so you can see it draws the wall
with an offset of 250 millimeters from
our reference line
so that's uh sometimes
handy uh this time it's not so let me
yeah okay so offset
um
resets itself to zero if you escape out
of the tool
radius um have no idea what the radius
is
we can actually check
yeah
it's a little bit laggy ah okay so
radius is basically a fillet of the wall
so we don't really care about the radius
at least for for for my example i will
not be using any fillet
corners
and joint status allow or disallow it's
basically when you make a corner of two
walls do you want them to merge into one
uh one geometry
or not geometry but would should all of
the
layers inside of the walls kind of merge
together nicely
so i always have it set to be allowed
all right let's actually do do something
let's draw something because this is
getting boring so i'll go to the website
and here i will just quickly read that
um we have three clients to choose from
right annabelle which is an arts curator
uh brian which is a car enthusiast or
clementine which is a musician and
i think i will go for animal
in in for this particular tutorial just
because i don't a
or annabelle
um and b for brian
huh
so
annabelle is an arts curator and is
looking to expand her gallery she wants
the ground floor of her house to be open
to public and should work as a small art
gallery exhibition area she will live
above this gallery so all other floors
need to be private
okay her stylistic
preference is minimalist which with
occasional strong color accents
she has
she has a cat no family so that will
help us determine
the the the living room or bedroom area
and and so on
okay
uh first floor public second floor
private uh
gallery in the first floor um all other
floors are living spaces
easy
let's jump back to revit
and let's let's plan this out so
you have a street here right
and you have people walking along and
you have
you want this area to be the arts
gallery right so i will say
i will say
the arts gallery itself
is going to be or rather the entrance is
going to be pushed in a little bit from
the street so that there can be
like a small gathering before an arts
exhibition opening or something like
that people like to go outside and smoke
and have a chat and not stay indoors
that much so you do need a little bit of
space in the front right you don't want
them to just be standing here on the
street so i will be
insetting
this uh this building a little bit
inwards
uh to do that i need one more grid line
because i like to keep things tidy so i
will choose my grid tool here
and instead of
drawing the grid line
i will do one
one fancy
not fancy but one additional like thing
with it which is
instead of here instead of drawing a
line a grid line
from point to point oh by the way sorry
forgot when you hover your mouse over a
tool it will show you what that tool
does very handy
um
i will choose this tool right here pick
lines
the clients will help me determine from
where do i
from which line do i create
a new grid line right
and then i will say
that actually
i will
my plan is to pick line b this this grid
line here
right
come on
okay it doesn't let me but that's fine
it at least it lets me pick the the
street
uh straight line that's fine as well so
i will be using this line here and i
will be offsetting it inwards by
i don't know 1.5 meters something like
that
i think 1.5 should should do the trick
yeah let's do 1.5 ish
uh meters so
i am picking the line with this tool and
here when where it says offset i will
choose 1500
for the offset right
and then i just pick this line and
already
without clicking it already shows me
where it's going to place the line if i
want to place it on the other side by
the way i can
i can just type in minus 1500 and it's
going to place it on the other side
okay
so click
that's it
create a third
um
[Music]
why is there's uh
no no no no no no sorry about that
for some reason there there was um
grid line d as well i don't want that
again grid
quick line
1
500
um
[Music]
come on down okay there we go so now i
just created one gridline that there was
a
i explained it to too much
and i made too many gridlines um right
so we have that oh right that's why
that's because i keep clicking on it
without actually
looking that i'm still creating
gridlines so this is how you can create
gridlines quite fast with that offset
offset tool but we don't need that so i
will just be deleting all of these
and i'll be just looking at gridline e
which i'll pull back
i'll pull back this one here
create a tick mark uh not
put the tick mark down
red line e that's actually not e that is
the new b
grid line
i wonder if it's going to let me do that
no it doesn't i first need to change the
grid line b here
to c
and this one is going to be gridline
there we go
we're good
okay so that's going to be the
inset of my
um
of my floor not my floor but off of my
first floor
walls
let's actually let's create the walls
right
so bam walls
uh finish face exterior great chain
great let's just do it bam bam
bam
bam bam and yes i know it's right now
unconnected but we are fine with that
okay
so we have done that right
and if i take a look at it in 3d view
bam there we go
[Music]
we have our
our walls uh here shown and they are
exactly eight meters high which is way
too much but that's that's okay we'll
fix that by the way if you don't like
this
wireframe view
it's not wireframe line uh hidden line
view
if you don't like this hidden line view
you can always go here to the
oh wait
there we go
you can always go here to the bottom
of the window and click on visual style
hidden line here and choose shaded for
instance and then you'll see the shaded
view i just prefer to keep it
clean at the start so i just use the
hidden line view
okay
we have that done
so now
i want to
actually create
um
actually connect sorry not create but
actually connect
these walls to level two right so that
if i need to for some reason change the
height of level two i can
layer down the line
so i will do that by
first of all i need to create level two
because here i only have level one right
the ground floor level
uh so i need to create level two and the
way you do it
is by actually um
describing it or marking it out in the
elevation view or in a section view
so to do that first of all we need to
create a section view or an elevation
view and this is where
actually creating views
before the design starts
start uh actually makes sense right um
so let's do that
um i will go to view
here view
and i'll choose
to create an elevation view actually
i'll make two of them one for the back
side of the building and one for the
front side right so elevation
click
that's in the view tab elevation click
and it's basically asks me would i like
to attach it to a grid and not not
really i don't really care about
attaching it to the grid i'll just do
something like this
right place it like that and it
immediately looks at the
[Music]
at the facade that i've made and i'll do
the same thing for
the side here
maybe a little bit further down there we
go
so we have two elevations here
one and two
and i can actually rename them as well
sorry
i first want to move move this bad boy
away
so these are basically the points from
which we start looking at elevations or
rather elevation markers
um i will select
my table
sorry my table is falling apart okay so
i will select one of them and i'll just
take a look at what what can be what can
be done with it so there are two ways of
how you can select it first one is let
me zoom in first
first way to select it is if you select
the circle right if you select the
circle there's not much that you can
that you can change here
right you can kind of add a type
and and
choose a different
and you even choose
yeah you can kind of choose a different
style for for this markup but other than
that nothing else
um
well you can add more elevations from
that point but we don't care about it
uh yes please delete it okay um
but what we do care about
is this little arrow here
this black arrow once we select the
arrow
then we have a lot of things that are
going on first of which if we zoom out
we can see this box here
uh partially dashed line box partially
blue line box that's uh that has
appeared so this box right here
basically tells us how wide
the elevation is going to be
right that view that we are going to
generate
how wide is it going to be
so i'm going to take that
and i'm going to push it to be quite
narrow
up until here
and quite narrow up until here right
because that's all we need
we just need it to be there
and
so so that's the width and these two
arrows here are the depth
so if i click and drag on those
i can say that i actually want to see
it in my elevation view i want to see
the background building if it's going to
show up but i do want to see it right
so i am kind of
describing how far we are going to see
that's one i'll do the same thing for
the other one
i'll change the width
like that
and the length
like that should be good enough you can
change the length
uh
any way you want as long as you know you
show the stuff that you want to show
um
i will just rename them because i think
that's that's kind of important
so let me just see which one is which
actually
uh yeah it will from time to time it
will ask you to
save the project sure i will just click
on save and here i just double clicked
on elevation 2a
and i'll just drag it out
so
sorry i i'm doing it automatically
sorry
um
when you have uh double clicked on
either elevation one a or elevation two
a doesn't matter
once you double clicked on them uh for
the first time they will generate the
view right so once the view has been
generated it's going to kind of load up
faster
um and let's say elevation one a
you can see this border that's clipping
out
or clipping away our
view
so i will select that border
and i will drag
on these these dots here i i'm able to
drag it so that i can see more
of this border
or within this border
like that and the width i will not be
messing around too much with the width
that's fine and maybe we can
get away with something like this
so this narrow thing right here is going
to be our building and if i look at it
in 3d view
i can see that um okay i can see that
we do see a balcony here
and in 3d view i can see balcony is
there that means that elevation 1a is
actually our street elevation and
elevation two a is going to be our
uh
garden elevation i don't know backside
elevation
so i will
just extend
come on
higher it's a little bit laggy but
that's fine that's that's not a big deal
there we go
so elevation
2a is our
back elevation so i will actually rename
them because i think that's important
you can right click on elevation 1a or
you can just
single click on its name
and choose to rename it to
street
elevation
come on elevation
and then elevation 2a is going to be
back
elevation
there we go that's it
so we have that done
and now
back to
[Music]
back to what we we had before
uh we we need to specify
our
uh levels right
in in the elevations actually now uh
let's let's create a section or rather
two sections first and then we will
do the levels so
back to level one
here we do have two elevations already
prepared now let's create two sections
so section markup or rather section is
generated through the view tab as well
it's under section here
if i click on it
it basically just asks me to give it uh
a line right draw a line uh through
which we will cut
uh so i will draw just draw a line right
through the middle of the building like
so
and can i click on that
yes i can okay so right in the middle of
that line
you can see the zigzag here if i click
on it then i can
then i'm able to
kind of drag away
that section line away from the building
i don't want it to be present
inside of the building because i'm going
to be designing uh like walls in it and
i don't want the section line to get in
the way
okay so that's our section it kind of
works in the similar way as our
elevations you have you know how wide it
is
and also how deep it is right
so here i'll just specify the depth like
so
yeah i think that's that's good so
that's our section a a
right and i can
i can rename it and so on we will do
that i think a little bit later
uh i'll just call it section one for now
i'll keep it as section one if we take a
look at it it's nothing too fancy
you know
it's just a bunch of a bunch of lines
nothing
nothing more
nothing fancy at all
just move it up
here we go perfect
okay um so so that is done
that's our section one and let's do
section two across section
so
bam bam
and
i will be repositioning the sections uh
later
of course
uh so that they show more
uh and that
that i'm not cutting at awkward places
but for now just having everything here
i think is great
so so that you don't forget
okay so we have that section two is also
generated
let me just make it nicer
[Music]
bam
right now it's not it's not gonna look
nice but that's fine we will make it
look nice layer down the line
okay
almost there
we will be finishing up by creating
floor floors
so level one
is here and as i mentioned before you
can add more levels as long as you're in
either elevation or a section view
so in elevation view i will just go to
[Music]
wait where is it
architecture
oh yeah sorry it's under architecture in
the architecture tab
it's
level
right so it's not under view tab it's
under architecture tab level as a level
to the model okay so the way i'm going
to work with this is i will be
rebuilding
right now i've been using the gener
generic levels i will just rebuild all
of the levels from scratch which is
going to be
easy uh quite quite fast so level
here
and i will just say
my first level
right doesn't it snap oh there we go it
does snap so
there's like
two lines here
i need to
make sure that i'm snapping to the
correct one
why are there two lines here let me see
three oh okay so the two lines are there
because my
plate here my ground plate has a
thickness
of course
so that's why
in let's say street elevation or that
doesn't matter back elevation uh we see
these two lines
right that that's the thickness of the
ground
so i do need the first one the top one
to work as my ground floor
level
from here
to here
it says level three but that's that's
that's fine that's fine uh level three
is okay
i'll hit escape
and we will be renaming them either way
that's level three
then
i will choose to rather than drawing
i'll choose to use the pick lines tool
because i have a grid line here
a picc lines tool
and i will say
offset
you know by how much will we offset from
here so i'm picking i'm going to be
picking this level 3
line which
it doesn't let me
pick that well hello
let me
i saw you ah there we go
so
we will be offsetting from this line and
for some reason
oh okay so it doesn't let me pick the
the grid line it only lets me pick lines
from the mall that's fine that's okay as
well
um
by by specifying the offset i will
specify the height of my first floor
right
so
let's go for three meters
because i think that's that's just a or
maybe the gallery space could be a
little bit higher the ceiling height
could be higher so let's go for three
and a half meters
so 3500
from here
up
there we go level four
right
and then then
um
all other spaces will be three meters
high right so the ceiling height will be
three meters so three meters here
um
three meters here let's
see let's see
can i fit
i'm just thinking if i can fit the the
whole building into three floors so
first floor is going to be the gallery
space which is
yeah that's just used up
second floor
um kitchen
living room
bathroom
third floor
bedroom work
work room
now we we won't be able to to fit
kitchen bedroom
kitchen living room and bathroom into
one floor so just in case i'll add a
third floor here or or fourth floor and
we'll see how we can kind of
work around with it
so that's our levels now it's time to
make them nice
let's escape out a bunch of times from
our
tool
and then let's just
make them nice in this in in this
particular view
so here i'll just make sure that
they're shown on both sides
even though we don't need it actually we
don't need it sorry sorry don't don't do
that don't do that
so let's untick
the right hand side and just keep it at
the
left hand side
and then here i'm just going to rename
them so i'll select level 3 and call it
hello level three
why do you not
yeah there we go or okay let's do it
this way
here where it says level three i'll just
click on the name of it and i'll just
call it
round floor
would you like to rename corresponding
level and views yes
becomes ground floor
level four
is going to be
first floor
yes
level five is going to be ah
accidentally
double clicked on it
level five is going to be
second floor
don't show me this message again there
we go
level six
third
four
and then we have level seven wait
am i making a skyscraper
let's see
uh so that's first or ground floor first
floor second floor
third floor
oh yeah and then it would be fourth
floor but i can just say yeah
let's keep it consistent so fourth
floor
okay
so that's done
uh let me
now delete level one and the site
um
floor plans because we don't need them
anymore
level one deleted site deleted there we
go
now we're good to go
so that's our ground floor
looks like that we'll need to kind of
make it nice again but that's fine then
we have our second floor third floor
fourth floor fifth floor uh our first
floor
actually the
the way it's arranged here sucks so i'll
just say
zero
dash ground floor
3500 dash
first floor
i hope you you understand what i'm what
i'm doing
here 6500 dash
this is in millimeters how high
each floor is
then we have
9500
dash
third floor
and we have
uh
12500
dash
or floor
yes to have all of them kind of stacked
up nicely because it goes along the
alphabetical order
all right
almost there
not almost there we're done with the
the floor plans let's see uh with adding
the floor plans so now i'll make
everything tidy again by just uh putting
down the tick marks where
uh where they need to be and
cutting open the sections so that they
are not in the way
uh while i'm doing that
questions that you will have are
well usually questions that students
have
can you just use the wall of this
building
of the surrounding building
rather than build your own wall here
because it becomes a double wall
the answer to that is no you can't you
need to build your own wall
um then another question would be
wait
yeah can you change the style of the
grid axes and the
elevation markups and the section
markups and whatnot
uh my answer to that is
yes you can as long as you download the
as you as long as you download them
i did the styles i mean
and honestly
it's too much of a hassle to find a nice
one and download it and get it get it
going so instead
my suggestion would be to
just stick stick to these ones
uh and if you want to make it nicer
then when you plot it out
when you plot this this out as a pdf
uh change it in photoshop
straight up i mean it's gonna take you
what 15 minutes to
to change all of the drawings
section markups and all
maybe 20 uh to change the section
markups and all of the plans uh where is
the tick mark there we go um
but it's it's you will have full control
over the style of it
um yeah yeah that that's that's about it
so it created a bunch of ceiling plants
as well uh every time when you create a
floor uh it will create a ceiling plan
as well we don't care about the ceiling
plans again and just to
be sure that you're not going into the
ceiling plans
delete them
because i i get so many questions about
the ceiling plants and
not not the ceiling plants but something
is not working and then we take a look
and
students are drawing in
in the ceiling plant trying to draw
walls in the ceiling plant never works
out
okay back to here ground floor
bam we have our walls
um and here you can see that our walls
are being constrained not to ground
floor but rather to level one so
let me
let me explain this a little bit more i
think i need to explain this a little
bit more every
geometry
in rhino almost every geometry in rhino
this is not rhino this is revit
goddammit every geometry in revit can be
and usually is
attached or constrained to some other
geometry or a thing an object
which makes revit quite parametric in
that sense if something changes other
things will follow along which is nice
but also it adds much more settings for
you to kind of remember and know about
one of those settings is
base constraint
so if i select this floor
this is not a floor this is a wall if i
select this wall right
here
in the ground floor plan
and i choose uh i i take a look at its
properties i can see that it's a basic
wall it's a generic wall nothing fancy
there
it does have a base constraint
right and it's constrained to level one
that's because we drew it in level one
even though level one doesn't exist here
anymore
it's still constrained to it so that
doesn't make any sense
right so we need to either redraw it in
ground floor so that
the bottom of the wall all always will
follow
the ground floor
the height of the ground floor
or
we can just change change it here base
constraint
move that out
find uh ground floor there we go
same thing for all other ones if you
hold down the control key you can select
many walls at once
and you can constrain all of them to
ground floor so now
if ground floor moves the walls will
follow along
then
let me actually have all of them
selected
then you have
a base offset this is basically how high
does the
do these walls are these walls offset
from the ground floor plane
right so right now it's zero meaning
that they are right on
the ground floor
and then you have
if it's 250 they'll kind of be floating
25 centimeters above the ground floor
then you have top constraint which is
unconnected
sure
and you have unconnected height so this
is basically
it's always going to have the same
height of 8 meters and it's just going
to be floating
in space if you mess around with the
height of the ground floor right
if you want it to kind of snap
to
let's say
first floor
right up to
top constraint up to level 3500 first
floor
then unconnected height becomes locked
right
and what that means is if i
drag this out
it's smaller
like that
right um
and if i go to
back elevation let's say
so
by the way you can have two views here
you do something like this right
so that's my 3d view of
with those walls and that's my back view
right
so now i can say
first floor elevation this guy right
here instead of 3500
i can say
4000
[Music]
right and see how this moved up let me
do that again from 4000 i will switch
this to 1500
very very small first floor but all of
the walls they follow along this is
super this is very very useful let's
come back to 3500
okay so that's great
um
and let me close 3d view
that's great let's jump back to our
ground floor plan
and continue
continue working on this
so by now
you already have
like um
the the perimeter for the first
floor
or the ground floor now let's do the
perimeter for the first floor
right here
right
so here
i want the
why doesn't it show
just a second
[Music]
okay for now we will not be
doing that
you will see something like this
which is okay i will show you
how to mess around with the view
later
later in the tutorials but for now you
don't really see in the first floor you
don't see the walls which are in the
ground floor that's fine because we have
these grid axes here and they are here
for a reason right
so
with these grid axes here
i will probably specify
i i will just draw another perimeter for
me to work with so i will create a wall
and here is going to be a generic wall
it's going to start from the first floor
perfect
um
it's going to be
actually not unconnected so i can either
specify it here or here doesn't matter
so it's not going to be unconnected it's
going to be connected to the second
floor since i'm drawing it in the first
floor right
the second floor
um and it's going to be
finished face exterior that's fine
yeah nothing else needs to be changed
and then i'll just draw it here and this
one i will draw
full perimeter
um
[Music]
oh that's not the full perimeter that's
too much of a
period
okay let me try it again wall
yes to the second floor that's perfect
uh we draw it from here
to here
just make sure that you snap to the
correct
um
that you snap to the correct points
there we go
bam
that's it hit escape a bunch of times
let's take a look at it in 3d view
boom how it looks like in
[Music]
in 3d view
right
so i have a little bit of a
of a nook here
or for people to catch a catch a break
during a
gallery opening or something like that
also
it's nice it's always nice to have
something inside
when it's raining
so that when you get a tumble for your
keys and so on you don't need to
stand in the rain
okay
so we have that done
actually maybe i want this to be
yeah let's do one thing so now i'm
designing i know sorry
bear with me i will create a grid line
an additional grid line so i'll select
i'll choose that i'm going to pick lines
and my offset is going to be 1500 again
and i'll just offset from grid line a
a new grid line which is grid line d
and then in the first floor
no first floor is fine
first layer is fine in the ground floor
i will actually take this wall
and i'll move it
i don't know if i can yes i can there we
go i'll just move it
to
grid line d
perfect
okay
so the reason why i did that is
now i have a possibility
to do a balcony here
right or for my second floor which is
great
that's exactly what i want
okay
let's jump back to okay so ground floor
is fine right now i'm just blocking out
the basic
volumes right
as as i'm
as i'm moving forward with this
so that's ground floor
first floor is here
second floor
for the second floor
so that's a balcony
do we do one more balcony here
do we make it smaller and smaller
that's the question
let's do it simple okay so here i'll
just create a wall uh that's gonna be
yeah locked to the third floor
and i'm just going to say from here to
here
nothing fancy from here to here to here
to here
here something like that
that's good i won't even show you that
third floor
and third floor i'm thinking of
creating one more grid line
and doing an offset of
two meters
uh yeah picking the line doing an offset
of two meters inwards
so that it kind of lines from grid line
a to grid line e
here
and the reason why i do two meters is
how did i know that it's two meters
for alignment is
first of all
it's it's always done in increments of
50 centimeters right these kind of
building offsets and so on usually
around 50 centimeters and here it's mere
uh one meter 500 so i just assume that
it's going to be one more step so that
that becomes two meters um oops
don't need that grid line
okay
so
here
i'm thinking of having it
okay so we're drawing a wall but it's
going to be a super small one
like that
okay let's take a look at it in 3d oh
and uh sorry i need to make sure that
it's
up to level four okay great so it is
locked to level four now
um so this is how it looks
the the block out how the blockout looks
like
that's not good
that's a pretty ugly
yeah i hate that
1400 no sorry uh 1440
centimeters okay so
what if we do straight up
10 meters
it's probably not going to be enough huh
all right that's actually
yeah but then you put on a roof and so
on so it becomes
shitty again
we will need to kind of take a closer
look at that and see if if it
if it looks bad with the roof on but for
now this is how this is how it looks
that's our block out okay
let's uh create some floor slabs right
because right now if i take a look at a
section of it
um and let's just shade it real fast
shade that section dash or save the
project
um
you don't really see
any any floor slabs that's because we of
course you don't see any floor slabs
that's because we haven't created any
the
so let's create some floor slabs
i'll show you how to
so i'll come back to ground floor
and
usually you don't really need to create
a floor slab from the for the ground
floor for a proposal level uh project
because it's already on the ground but
uh whatever let's go to architecture tab
and let's choose
floor
here
floor
and it's going to ask us to
basically what kind of floor do we want
so 1500 is a little bit thin
um
i'm thinking more
about
well
let's let's see this is only three
meters well yeah around three meters
actually the thousand five hundred is
not that thin that's fine
let's use that
and here i can either draw
a boundary line
or i can pick walls right so i can just
click
click
click click that's easy right just
picking walls
uh or i can pick lines as well you know
as long as you create a perimeter it's
going to make a floor slab inside of
that perimeter
this tool does that
it's really
really simple
how it works
so yeah
let me just hit
finish editing mode
that's it that's our
floor slab right there
um right
same thing for first floor
actually let's take a look at this
section
so the floor slab goes down
into the ground
which is fine
there are going to be
things that we will need to
kind of investigate with with the other
uh with
the the first floor
also why are you you need to be here and
you need to be gone there we go
so let's do first floor because it's
going to be a little bit more tricky due
to the balcony and the cantilever here
first floor
there we go a floor
slab
and here we have
a balcony right remember that we
hope you do
we have a balcony here
and we have a cantilever here so let's
see how we can do this
i will just pick lines for now and i'll
just say this this this
and this
these four lines here
except lines cannot intersect each other
um
continue okay so it doesn't let me uh
intersect the lines that's fine i can
just draw the lines myself
that's okay let me cancel quit uh are
you sure you want to discard four yes uh
so i will just do it again
this time i'll choose floor and instead
of picking lines i will just draw my own
line
um
like that
that
like that easy right so i'm just using
the line tool
once i'm done i hit the accept button
here
uh would you like walls to go up to this
floor's level to attach to its bottom
would you like
ah would you like walls that go up to
this floor's level
you attach to its bottom
attach i don't know
okay so we have our floor slab here
um this is sketchy let's look at it in
this section
actually looks good
okay
looks looks not not that bad looks fine
uh this one though
this
should extend to the outside
of well
not really it shouldn't it shouldn't
extend to the outside of the wall but
oh me i know i know i know i know how
we're going to deal with this so
let me explain
this wall and this wall
and this floor make a very awkward
connection here what we want is we want
this wall to go into the ground as if it
was a foundation block and we could do
foundation blocks i know but
i'm lazy so i'll just extend these walls
so let's go to ground floor
and select these floors
and where it says
um
base offset
i'll say minus 500 millimeters hit apply
go to section one
and now they offset
downwards by minus 500 millimeters so we
have foundation blocks kinda
good enough
for this kind of
project
um
one two
three three more
or rather two more floor slabs and the
roof but i will make a flat roof so it's
i'm just going to use a floor slab to to
make a flat roof
um
or should i make a angled roof
i'll do both i'll show you how to make
an angled roof and then i will make a
flat roof afterwards so
second floor
there we go
let's do floor
and here
it's going to be very straightforward
it's just going to be picking walls
because there's no cantilevers there's
no balcony so i'm just picking floors uh
picking walls
attached
um
highlighted walls are attached
to but miss the highlighted targets
[Music]
yeah sure okay
let's see sometimes it gives you errors
but i think we are
ah
that's why
so we don't want to attach huh
let's let's investigate investigation
time
so the reason why this happened
so that's fine
that's okay
but this is not
uh the reason why this happened is that
these walls
the bottom ones i think or maybe the top
ones now the bottom ones the bottom
walls
had to move down
since we said to attach they moved down
to
let the floor slab in but the problem is
that
the floor slab
only reaches the inside of the walls not
the outside so
honestly i'm going to fix it by
detaching here
let me ctrl z
delete
let me do it again
actually i could have just left it as it
is but
i want to show you
um how to do it so floor
this time i'm going to yeah sure i'll
i'll pick walls again
intercept
but here i'll say don't attach
right
and now
technically yeah now it's fine and in
this section it also looks fine
good we fixed it
now this is going to be a little bit
more tricky
but we'll make it we'll make it
believe i believe so third floor
the floor slap is going to go up until
here up until grid line a
while the walls end here so we get
one more balcony
and also here we get a balcony
or do we wait
i don't remember yeah so we got two
balconies here
we get a lot of balconies we need to
take a look at that later on um
so in third floor i'm going to
create a floor
which is going to
[Music]
which is going to go
between grid line a
and grid line c
with this one right here okay
so let me just draw it uh
it's it's just going to be faster to
just draw
draw it like that
there we go
except
this time we attach i believe
yep
um let's take a look at it in the
section
yeah that's
good enough i think
yeah okay
so that that that that looks good
so we have our
our volume here
um can i
and this is our volume with the shadows
not much to so you can turn on the
shadows by
clicking on the shadow icon of course
i wonder how do you
how do you change this yeah send
settings there we go send settings
um
top
left
now
sign settings
up left
and there we go
not much is going on but you know kind
of helps you understand
the volume a little bit better maybe
maybe i don't know
okay
so we have that
let us
continue
um so there are two more things that i'm
gonna do and then we will finish up this
portion of the tutorial
um tutorial number one
so
i am going to show you how to make a
roof
so making a roof is going to be
quite fun let's let's jump to
let's jump to the third floor
no the fourth floor that's our where our
roof is going to be
and
i just need to know so our
walls go between e and b
and they reach here so it's it's between
e
and it's
between b so here we have our floors
by the way
if you are tired of kind of playing
detective and not seeing it you can go
to
view range here
view range
and choosing that the
view depth how deep do you see
uh goes a little bit
a little bit deeper so let's say
unlimited sure unlimited view depth hit
apply
hit okay
and now you will see the
the floors
all of the floors below below fourth
floor so now you see the the walls here
um
and we will
add a roof so this is going to be an
angled roof
click
there we go and it's basically uh it's
the same way as drawing a floor slab
right you just choose um
[Music]
for instance the walls click click click
click like that
and here you can choose
not
there we go so here you can choose what
kind of
sorry
um
having having a stroke i think
here you can choose what kind of angle
the roof will will have so now i'm just
kind of clicking on all the walls and
hitting accept and this is the roof and
if we take a look at it in 3d
uh it's the ugliest roof
that you could that you could find
let me just try to snap it there we go
that's done um let's take a look at it
there it is
so there's a lot of problems with it
right
the main one
being that it's
there there's this kind of
very weird gap where the the walls end
and the roof begins that makes
absolutely no sense whatsoever
right so so that's that's bad
of course
um
and other things are
what if you don't want
all all of these slopes to be like that
right what what if you want
um
a roof like this right
uh can can you control it of course you
can right so i'm going to do it again
but this time i'm going to show you how
do you fill
how do you not make this this ugly gap
here right so i'll delete the roof and
i'll
create a new one
roof there we go roof
and i'll just
choose
by the way you need you can choose what
kind of a
roof you want is it concrete is it uh
generic i'll just see generic doesn't
matter
um
and here instead of choosing the walls i
will choose
to just draw a line i i that's what i
prefer to do
that
that
that
come on
and that's why we save by the way
there we go
such a mess
that
oops slightly messed it up but that's
fine we will fix it and
i mean that point
there we go
oh my god
when you zoom in okay so while this is
like when you zoom in
too much it's going to redraw the whole
model
at a higher detail and that's why it
lags um i absolutely hate that thing
about
revit but
they insist on doing it so yeah
whatever
okay so
here i just need to
move
those
i'll just need to move that point
but that's fine
uh for now let's just
accept it and this is how the the roof
looks like now
a little bit better why is it sticking
out here
why is it
is it sticking out it is sticking out
did i mess up i think i messed up
i think i
anchored it to the wrong no i didn't
wait
so it's not sticking out here what about
section two
and it is indeed sticking out here but
it's sticking out here because i messed
up the other side oh yeah that's
of course that that's why uh that's
because i i misclicked on the other side
while i was
right here so this is the part that's
sticking out
so let's fix it you can double click on
the roof and then you can
change the
change the points where where they are
that
uh
[Music]
cancel
how are you even joined don't don't lie
to me
okay or
or you can just draw it again because
it's
faster
oh my god to do it that
way okay so let's draw it again
click
click
this time don't mess up
click
click
click there we go
okay
we have our clean room roof right
uh now i'm going to click on this modify
icon here so that i can select my
um um
[Music]
lines
and notice how here we have the angles
so i can define um
the angles of all of the slopes
of each individual slope of the roof so
here by default it's set to 30 but what
if we do 75
for this side
75 for this side
and then these are going to be
dasher let's let's do 75 here as well
why not why not
this is gonna be fun okay so we hit uh
finish
we take a look at it and that's our new
roof
great
[Music]
so that's with 75
degree angle again uh not the roof that
we want
so let's double click on it again
or not
let's double click on it again there we
go and let's mess around with it even
further so
these icons right here specify which
lines define slope right and if i select
one of these lines let's see this one
it will have a tick mark here that says
define slope so for instance if i were
to
choose this line and say that it doesn't
define slope
and choose this line and also say and
tick the part that says define slope
so that it doesn't define slope here as
well and change this to something more
reasonable let's say 45 degrees
and this one change this to 45 degrees
as well
hit accept
now we have a proper
you know a proper roof just like this
one right
well the the walls are disconnected from
it but other than that i think it's fine
so actually that's that's important how
do we connect the walls
to the roof
so what we can do is we can go to the
third floor
and we can choose the walls that we want
to connect
like that we choose these walls right
and we want to say yo
extend these walls
until they attach
to the roof so attach
so i'll go to
when i have this wall selected i'll
choose
this tool attach top base
like that
and then i'll just simply click on the
roof
so you might need to change your view or
something like that or
just have two views opened and click on
the roof
and click on the roof
there we go
so then it attaches
and then you
yeah you hit escape a bunch of times and
take a look at it and uh
yeah that's good that's that that's good
that's uh that's a wall that's attached
to the roof
right
so that's uh
that's how you work with a sloped roof
nothing too fancy right
another thing is how do you work with a
flat roof
and this one i i prefer um
i just i don't know i i prefer flat
roofs so i'll delete this
right so immediately the walls come back
to being normal because they don't have
anything to to attach to
and instead in the
fourth floor i'll just create a floor
right
i'll just create a floor i will just
choose
um
i'll just pick walls i think yeah let's
just do it super simple pick walls
intercept
uh would you like two walls to go up to
this floor no no we don't we want to
keep it as it is so don't attach
uh would you like to join geometry cut
the overlapping volume out of the walls
up
yeah sure
whatever
okay
and we're gucci
so
ah battery no
no battery come back
i wonder
it's going to be alive now
right there we go
hey
okay good
um
where was i
oh yeah
one last thing is
i am going to be doing concrete railings
um so i'm going to be showing that how
to do you know for these balconies of
course they need railings uh so i'm
going to be doing concrete railings uh
you might want to do you know
regular railings that's that's fine as
well it's just remember that by default
revit has really really ugly
rails
so
you know
take it with caution right
use that tool with caution i will show
that in in the next tutorial but for now
concrete railings those are basically
walls right nothing nothing fancy so
let's take a look uh i will need a a
railing on the
third floor
two railings actually on the third floor
there and there
and also i'll need a railing on the
first floor
yes first floor railing in the garden
view and a third floor railing okay so
let's start with first floor
first ah that's a tank twister first
floor railing
uh right here
right
and i'll just grab a wall this time i
don't need a
30 centimeter
wall
um i'll just be using um
[Music]
block work maybe
now let's go for
generic uh
140 millimeters
yeah that that's fine
so basic generic wall 140 mil
um finish face exterior height
this time it's going to be
unconnected and it's going to be the
height of the railing so um
let's go for
a meter
a meter is a little bit
low for railing but i think that's fine
usually it's
1.1 let's go for 1.1 there's no
um there are cats there so
i don't know why i said that
doesn't matter okay so we do have our
railing there
oh it even has an ugly
hatch
oh i don't like that hatch
i wonder if we can get rid of it
hidden line
so
this happens
sometimes uh not sometimes it's usually
the case that uh certain types of
geometries have certain times of
representation you know in certain
drawings
so this one
in particular has
this ugly ugly
brick work hatch
which we can i believe
fix
okay first of all let me escape
no i don't want to make a floor quit i
think cannot be under yes
okay uh so if i select this is going to
be me actually investigating how to get
rid of that hatch
if i select all of these walls and i add
a type
so i click on edit type here we have
the graphics and maybe here i can choose
to not have a hatch
yeah no pattern
hit ok
hit apply
yeah that
that doesn't care
that doesn't care at all
uh there's one more thing that i could
do at the type
basic wall
structure added structure
concrete messing i believe it's
somewhere here
so that's
thermal and that's concrete masonry so i
could change
change it here
with this block or sorry this this
that's cut pattern surface pattern i
could change it here but i really
don't want to
really really don't want to
[Music]
let's leave it let's leave it as it is
for now um yeah let's not mess around
with that
sorry for that intermission uh hope you
didn't get too bored with me
um let's add
more
uh
walls here i can't look at it i'm just
going to
to change it
i'm just going to change its
type so i'm going to select these walls
and
just do
foundation generic 200 ml i could do 200
ml or 135
yeah there we go okay so i'm i've just
chose a different
different type of uh
wall
for that okay so now let's draw a wall
not masonry but rather 135 mil
wall
from here to
oh it goes along the center line no no
no no no no no
so we will need to switch it
push it around
yeah yeah save project
um
so it goes along finish face exterior
it goes along
it's unconnected it's 1100
no
yes 1100
it's chained
has this type
perfect
that's all we need
and then we just draw it
straight up
bam bam
bam
enter
that's drawn
and then we have another
we have it
in another site notice how i'm not
creating any geometry whatsoever
in the
in the 3d view
yeah that's that's how you work with
revit
so here i'm going to
draw up
am i in the floor
escape out of that sorry about that draw
walls
from here
uh oops that was my bad a long
long there we go enter
so we have our
railing here as well
all right i think we are
we're fine i think we're good with with
the
with the geometry so far
uh one last thing that i want to show
you before we finish up
uh for today for this tutorial
is
as you probably can tell i'm not a big
fan of the user interface
of
revit
and the clunkiness
of it um
so one last thing that i want to show
you
is called a
a section box and
for that i need to
go to so so if i in 3d view
if i actually don't want to see all of
this crap
right
especially here what the hell are you
delete
there we go
if i don't want to see all of this crap
i can
just create a section just a small
section of the
building itself right so in 3d so i can
do that by going to
modify
yeah i can go to modify tab i can select
all of the objects here
all of the objects
and i can click on this icon right here
which is called selection box
bam
so it will create this kind of a
box for me
around my
everything that i have selected and i
can once i select that box i can click
and drag
the side sides of it
right
so that i only
i only see
my building
and also that's that's a good way of how
to investigate uh the inside of the
building so my box is a little bit
you know the angle is not that great so
let me just switch it to top view here
real fast in 3d by just clicking on the
on this icon right here top
and i will just rotate
what the
oh it rotates around that
that point why
um again we do it again rotate this time
i will actually look at
the tools here so i'll say
center of rotation place
i will place the center of rotation here
perfect
and i will rotate it
like so
bam
that's good enough right
um that's it uh then we can go back to
our 3d view
by just clicking on this you know
dragging on on on this box here
not box yeah it is a box right on the
top right hand side
and now i can mess around by just moving
in the section box and looking at my
at my geometry
right
and that's my block out for now
i will change the angle of the sun
[Music]
do i even care i don't care
so boston sure i'll just change the time
lie
okay that's
5 p.m
that's my bad 12
no
morning
no even more
yeah that's night time right
uh
summer solstice apply
9 a.m
good eight that's that's even better
okay
so now the sun is shining inside of my
um inside of my building
through this section
okay i think that's that's good enough
for for
for today
uh so the task is
right now after you've watched tutorial
one to make this kind of a block out
very basic block out of
the volumes that you're going to
have
in the
you know in between squished in between
those two buildings
that you are going to put function in
uh into tomorrow
so that's that's the task
um for those of you who are not sure how
you'll manage to fit in you know the
bedroom and and whatnot
um i would suggest just taking a piece
of paper or
autocad or whatever and just drawing out
the plan basic basic plans you know with
the staircases and whatnot
just to know what you
what you actually want to do right what
you actually want to accomplish
here i am not doing that just to save
time
um
so my building is going to be worse uh
much much worse than your buildings
right
so other than that i think we are
um
we're done here
go get to work and i'll see you tomorrow
so
in part one we have finished doing the
block out
so this is what i would call uh
you know a good enough block out for us
to start detailing so we basically have
the whole proportion going and
everything seems to be in order
in this regard so now uh what i want to
do is i want to focus on
um shall we go for doors and windows
perhaps
yeah let's go for doors and windows so
i'll show you
different techniques and different ways
on how you can
create doors and windows in your revit
file so
to begin let's add a door let's add an
entrance door to our building
i'll go to ground floor
here and actually
at this stage i really
like doing like i really like splitting
um this view into two so
here i have my 3d view
and my ground floor view right these two
views if you don't see a 3d view just
double click here right
and it will open up the 3d view for you
so we have these two tabs these two
views
and basically what i want to do is i
just want to take this 3d view
and drag it
away
all right like so so now it's like a
separate window that is not docked
anywhere and then just taking it and
dragging it to the side
like so
will
eventually show me this
right this blue rectangle once i see
this blue rectangle i will release my
mouse button and then this 3d view gets
docked so now i'm working
in two views at the same time or rather
i see two views at the same time which
is super convenient
so
let me just
cut away that part
so that's my box selection tool remember
we are using it
um
and i'm using it to just cut away the
bits that i don't need i'll maybe even
cut deeper
into into these surrounding buildings
just so that i only see the
my
almost only see my building
something like that okay so that is no
no
now that is not obscured
okay so this is our entrance area
uh which is which relates to this wall
right here you can see once i select
this wall here it will show up here
get highlighted here as well
and here i just want to add a door so
how do you do that well you select the
door tool uh well i zoomed in so now we
wait there we go
i click on the door tool and here before
i start adding it it will ask me for
what kind of door do i want
so this is a single flush door 2.1
meters high 0.9 meters 90 centimeters
wide this is like a typical
typical door
and actually there's not a lot of
options here to choose from so i will be
choosing the default you know the
regular doorway
i think that's that's absolutely fine
i'll just add it
do we center it
probably just do it like that
bam
so i have just added the door and let's
say um
let's say i want
a layer down the line i will want to add
a shelf here or i will want to have a
possibility to add a shelf here so we
know that the shelf width is 60
centimeters
so the way i do it is
i will just
let me just see if i can
hello
i'm i zoomed in too much again just give
me a second
give not me give right uh rabbit a
second
two to catch up there we go
oh my god
it's quite a quite a slow program
ain't gonna lie
not responding huh
well that that calls for a coffee break
zoom out there we go
and i'll just click on modify
here this modify button
there we go
i will select the door
and now i can
here this this dimension i can add i can
write rather
what kind of dimension i want instead of
zero instead of the door being flush
with this wall i can add 600 millimeters
enter
that is wrong minus 600
that is correct
so the correct way as well of course
and thus we
now have this gap here where we will be
able to put a shelf or you know a
seating area anything like that usually
i i do this for
for a rack
for clothes rack
for the entrance
so that's how you add a door that's
that's basically it right you you just
kind of do it you just add a door
um another thing is adding a window so
while we're still here in our entrance i
i will be adding a window here
in this area
so
it's done in a exactly same way as the
door i'll select the window
tool
and i will choose what kind of window i
want i think i'll just go for the
default one because these guys have too
many subdivisions i don't want that many
subdivisions so i'll just use the
regular one
and
i'll choose this the type of it
so let's say
that's
90 centimeters by 1.8
meters i think that's that's gonna be
okay
or let's do
let's do 40 centimeters
by 1.8 meters i think that's going to be
cooler
like that
and here i can specify how high the
window is going to be
right so that's before me clicking on
the wall i can specify how high this
window can be or i can do that layer
layer down the line that's fine as well
so let me just
put it in
[Music]
probably
maybe closer to the door
there we go something like that so i
constantly check the dimensions to see
if they are correct and 300 ml i think
is fine so we end up with having
the door and this kind of a
narrow window inserted
let me click on the modify tool again
select the window and see what we can
what we can change with it so the first
thing is cell height
and the second thing is head height
right so in terms of cell height i can
say well what if it's 500 millimeters
hit apply
see the window just moves up
and then the head height updates as well
so now
let's say i want the window to be
aligned the height
the top of the window rather to be
aligned with the door
the way i do it is i will just select
the door and just double check so the
head height of the door is 2.134
meters
so if i select the window and here for
the head height i type in two one three
four
hit apply
ah yes of course
it gets aligned it does get aligned with
the door but i forgot the how is that
called the framing the framing of the
door and i assume the framing of the
door is like um
that looks like five or maybe ten
centimeters no that's definitely not 10.
so that looks like a 5 centimeter
framing so i will just add
5 centimeters to this head height
which is going to be a total of 2184
millimeters
and that looks right
i think
maybe not
yeah we're one centimeter
away
two one
nine four
i could just yeah probably i should do
this i could just kind of select the
door right and go to edit type and find
the trim
extension here
so apparently trim width
is set to be 76
millimeters
so i will just change it to
50. apply
so now it is indeed 5 centimeters
and now if i change this back to 2 1 8 4
apply
there we go now they are aligned so it's
a little bit fiddly uh edit type lets
you edit the type of the door itself so
you can make adjustments to how the door
looks like same thing for the window
um right so we have that done now
uh nothing too fancy but you know
it is
it it it is working
so that's good
um
and that's
what
we will visit that partly ah no never
mind that's that's the surrounding
building so that's not not an issue
um
so that's basically how you add doors
and windows right nothing too fancy by
the way if you want to change
the type of a window once you have
inserted it you can same thing for the
door so you just select the window you
go to prop
you go to the properties tab and you
just choose a different type right
bam it changes
and now we need to fish out which one
yeah it was this one good
um so that is that
in terms of
let me do it again for the
for the other side just so that
we are on the same page
and everyone is following along or
rather
maybe i want this
to be full glass
right this whole area perhaps i want it
to be full glass
i can do that by
first carving out
a hole in the wall
and then adding
what's called the curtain curtain
curtain wall inside of that opening
so to do an opening
to create an opening you can either
create a vertical or a horizontal
opening and the vertical opening is just
called a
wall opening nothing fancy and
the horizontal one or rather maybe i
should call this the vertical one so the
shaft is a vertical opening while the
wall opening is horizontal right
so yeah again the the
shaft is is
[Music]
you carve away from what's called
floor slabs and
ceilings and
roofs
with wall opening you carve away from
the wall
so i will just select that tool
which will basically ask me to
what does it ask me
that's a rectangular opening in a
straight uh or curved wall so for that i
probably need to do it in 3d right or
maybe we can do it in 2d let's see
click
no click yes
okay so it's basically two clicks uh let
me do that again because this was a a
bit dodgy
uh
wall opening
click
click
click there we go so you select the wall
and you see then you
say from where do you start opening and
where do you end so here it's it's a
little bit wonky um you can see how what
kind of hole it made but we can make a
bunch of adjustments uh
later um that's that's going to be easy
to do
and that layer is now actually
so let me click on modify
and here you can see that i can select
the opening the shaft i can indeed
select it
and i can change its measurements right
so here i want a precise measurement of
three meters let's see if that's gonna
gonna work yeah it is gonna work and i
want it to be centered right so that's
103 and that's 97 that doesn't work i'll
just do
100 by 100
right so 3 meters
10 centimeters 10 centimeters so we have
this this opening here
and the height of it
right
i can change the height of it as well so
first things first let's check the
the bottom
so the bottom
here the base offset is minus 19.2
for some reason i don't want that i will
just say base offset is zero hit apply
so it gets moved up a bit
and then the top
offset so that is from the
[Music]
from the first floor level you can see
that top constraint is said to be up to
level 3500
right so it's it's from this level here
um
it's being moved down by one point uh
[Music]
one meter eight centimeters right which
is a very weird offset so actually for
for this kind of window i will say
uh minus
minus 500 ml i think that's that's going
to be okay
so it gets moved closer there we go so
we have our our opening here
which is ready to
uh accept or or
now we are ready to put in a curtain
wall inside of it
the way we do it
is we just
create a wall
we start creating a wall and in the
properties you scroll down until you see
curtain wall option
right and here there's like exterior
glazing storefront curtain wall so we
will just be creating a regular curtain
wall
like that
um and we will say
that wall goes along the center line
that's fine
[Music]
yeah all of that seems okay
let's just start drawing it and see what
happens right
so this is
the default settings top constraint
unconnected that's fine
and let me just try and draw it through
the middle point of this wall
from here
to here
there we go okay so that is done
um it's basically it just created a
single
glass panel right now and you can see
that that panel doesn't even reach the
top so we need to somehow
be able to reach
apologies
we need to reach
the top of this hole and the way we do
it i believe is by just no we can't well
technically we can by just saying that
it needs to be up to
the first floor level
right
but the top offset needs to be the same
as the top offset of our
hole
which we used 500 millimeters for right
so it goes up to level one
uh and the top offset is minus 500
millimeters
hit apply
it didn't change why didn't it change
that's because
we are still in
place wall tool and not edit wall tool
that's my bad
sorry about that so we actually need to
escape out
completely so hit escape until you don't
have any tools
running we need to do that
and
then we select
this glazing
wall
how is it called curtain wall sorry this
curtain wall
we selected and then here we can change
the settings so that was my bad
before i was changing the settings for
the next
curtain wall that i'm going to be
creating
so top constraint from unconnected i
changed this to first floor
and top offset i changed this to minus
500 and now it should be good to go
there we go so now it's all tied up
okay so we have our
uh
single
glass
piece here
which is not you know it's okay but it's
it's maybe not something that
we necessarily want perhaps we want to
have a little bit more divisions and so
on of course
it
is it possible to make it like that
technically yes but
this would cost more than the rest of
the building so
instead let's let's add a few divisions
so i am going to escape out of all of
the tools
and here in the architecture tab i'll
find curtain grid tool
so this is going to be
actually once i hover my mouse over it
it shows what it does it's going to
separate
the glass panels into
a smaller panel right with a grid
so curtain grid select that
and here in the plan view
um
i am just going to kind of divide it up
and i'm thinking of um
perhaps we can do
one meter
here
and one meter here right so two
divisions right
every one meter
like that and then in the
let me jump in here in the perspective
view
i will say that
at 2.2
meters i also need a division
this kind of indicates that i will have
the center piece as a doorway i'm able
to use it as a doorway and the doorway
is not going to be like three meters
high
which
reduces the costs
dramatically
so
once you're done that
escape escape
hit escape a bunch of times once you've
done that you are able to um
well you will see that the glass has
been separated into parts but there is
no framing yet so we need to add the
frames
and the way you add frames is by
creating millions so frames are called
millions right
i will select that tool mullion
like that
and it's going to say
uh first of all what kind of mullion do
do we want right it's going to ask in
the properties what kind of million do
we want and there's like a bunch of
different
options
50 by 150 ml is is a pretty
intense one i want a little bit thinner
one so i'll just use the 30 millimeter
square million
so that's a cross section it's like
three by three centimeters it's super
thin it's unrealistically thin but i
think that's fine can we add the type of
it
yeah we can even add a type and we can
add any thickness we want but i will
stick to
to the default one that's that's fine
so we have our mullions and then here it
asks me to select grid lines right so i
can either select grid lines one by one
and these divisions are
grid lines they are called grid lines
i can select them one by one or i can
select all of them at the same time
so i'm thinking of just
going to town and just selecting all of
them
and clicking
so i just selected that tool and clicked
on the gridlines and
now uh the framing has been placed and
you can see it here as well
right those those black dots that's
that's the framing perhaps um
let me undo ctrl z
and instead let me actually use the
bigger one just so that you can see
better uh these these divisions so again
i selected the 50 by 150 mil
all grid lines
select
bam big boys
right
okay so we have our curtain wall here
set up
you can do the same thing for multiple
uh multiple floors as well that's that's
fine um you just make a larger shaft
actually maybe i should should show you
how to do it
um
can do i show you here or here maybe
here
let's do a glass facade right in the
front of the of the building
so i will go to
my
sorry now i'm just starting to design it
i'm trying to figure out
a nice
nice design for this um
so let's say in our first floor
ah
that's the wrong wrong side
and now we need to wait for it to load
up so first floor load it up on the
right hand side no i want it here
so in our first floor i will also create
a
a shaft opening
so sorry a wall opening like that
and i will create one from
uh
on this wall from here
to
here something like that
but this one actually i want to
be a little bit
less
wide
so i'll just say
something like this
perhaps so let's go for 1.5
meters
that's 1.5 millimeters that's my bad
i keep forgetting too that i'm drawing
everything in millimeters here
um usually in rhino i do block outs in
mirrors and then switch to millimeters
once i do a
detailed project
1500 right
and this dimension needs to be zero
uh can't keep elements joined
that's fine i will just say unjoin
elements
ah but then it makes that mistake huh
so this is where it it starts becoming a
little bit
just your
regular revit things right uh let me
undo
and here instead of zero
oops
here instead of in this case instead of
300 millimeters let me write 500
something like that so we have a 20
centimeter gap here i think that's fine
um let me while i'm at it let me make
another shaft here
from here
let's see
can i type in
500
oh
yes i can but it lags
so this is another way of how i'm
creating shaft so while i'm still in
shaft creation tool
i am able to kind of continue
adding shafts to this
but it's not being cooperative at all oh
that's
that's my bad
so
i forgot that i'm creating a wall
opening and not a shaft so i
accidentally cut away from the floors
not from the wall
oopsie
control z
uh
disregard
yes
save the project sure okay we're back
i'm ah
sorry
let me just create a wall opening not a
shaft opening i will show you how to
create a shaft opening in just a second
but now we are just creating wall
openings
like that
modify select this and here we just
start typing in the dimensions so this
one is going to be like 600 mil
and it's going to be
let's say
or actually here
this dimension is going to be 200 mil
away
something like that yeah i think that's
gonna look okay
and now it's just the height right i
need to
i i need to fix the height of it so
i'm just going to
select the first shaft opening and i'm
going to say that the top constraint of
it is up to
the third floor
like that
and the top offset is
um
let's go for zero
hit apply
doesn't cut huh
that's weird
i wonder why
perhaps it's because i made it in
wait
yeah that's
understood that's because
these are two separate walls
right
and this guy
this shaft opening can only cut through
the one so that but that's that's not a
problem i will just
move it down and i will say that the
the constraint is the second floor top
offset is
zero
apply hit apply
same thing for this one
not for this one or
for this one top offset
zero
apply
there we go and now we just need these
two uh shaft openings to go to
the second floor as well
so i'm just going to do it manually
real fast
so let me jump to the second floor
that's 20
that's 20 that's 60. don't remember this
one but we'll figure it out
uh should be good
uh so let me just drag this one in here
second floor
there we go
and i'll do this as fast as i can once
this stops lagging
while opening
on this wall from here
to here
from here
to here okay we have two wall openings
this one is
200 mil this one is probably thousand
five hundred
um oh so that then it changes this
200
and this one
i don't know
i don't know
this dimension but that's fine because
we will get it by changing this
so this one is 600
that is 200
and then automatically that dimension
kind of locks in place
in being 700 so
now we have one more shaft
that's great
and all we need to do is just
say that top offset of it is zero
like that
and that our top offset is zero as well
apply
uh
why is this higher than oh this one is
also that uh so sorry we need to
move it down a bit because we are
going into the floor slab
so the floor slab is
150 millimeters wide or or thick so the
top offset actually needs to be minus
150
apply
so that we're not going into the floor
slab um
this one come on come on just let me
there we go
minus 150.
okay so here we have our shaft openings
and i'm just going to jump back into
first floor where i'm just going to
create
the the curtain wall again wall
architectural
curtain wall
from here
to here and then from here to here
right so we have our our walls
modify
um
so
sometimes it creates a wall inwards in
inside like
in in the wrong
direction so the way you fix it is by
you don't really see it on the screen
but there are two arrows here
which let you change the orientation of
the wall right so you can switch them up
so i'll do that i will switch the
orientation of these walls uh then i
just need to
for the first one i just i will just go
to top constraint and see that actually
it's to the third floor not the second
floor and the top offset is actually
minus 150
due to the thickness of the floor slab
same thing for here
top offset minus 150
up to level
three
apply
there we go so we have our two
curtain walls set up now all i need to
do is just just add a grid again to them
um so here i'll just add one division
one vertical division here i don't need
to add any vertical divisions
right
and then i'll jump into 3d and just
hovering my mouse over the
vertical edge of the curtain the curtain
wall i am able to add horizontal
divisions
so i'll probably add
probably add a division here thousand
five hundred
year thousand five hundred
and
it doesn't really let me add 1500 here
but this seems okay
um and then same thing here a thousand
five hundred thousand five hundred
bam 1500
or
1425 that's fine
so we have our grids set up
and then i'll go to modify tab or to
i'll click on the modify button
i'll click on million and do the same
thing you know rectangular million
all grid lines i'll choose the button
that says all grid lines
and see that all of these need
rectangular millions right
and these also need rectangular moles
so now
all of this
is kind of done it's kind of set up
right
we have our
uh our
facade
done
last thing that i want to do i will not
be messing around with the back side
back side would also probably i would
add a curtain grid of some sort
i will instead just add a doorway and a
window here in the in the top
so let me go to the
let's go here let me go to the
third floor
come on load up there we go
third floor
bam bam bam
still loading there we go
door
regular door just add it
probably
600 ml again something like that
so we have our door and then
click on modify window
add a window also like a narrow window
um 300 millimeters away from the door
like that what the hell was uh well it
worked out
so the window is slightly too low uh we
will fix that by just adjusting the
head height two one three five um for
for this window is actually it needs to
be to 185 that's what we remember from
our previous insertion of of this window
that's it right that's that's it we
have um some sort of a facade it's not
the greatest
for sure
but
you know it's
okay
it's good enough to show you the the
tools
um so that is that
now let's
look at how can we add
in
door doors doorways inside of the
building
um
not put doorways walls walls and stairs
inside of the building so i'll go back
to ground floor
and i'll add a staircase first so that's
the first thing that i'm going to do
is add the staircase so
this is going to be a little bit
more tricky
not not necessarily tricky but um
i will
go to the architecture tab and i'll
choose stair
here and here is the stair creation tool
right so i am able to
either create a straight staircase
which is just straight up
that and by the way given the height of
each step and so on
and the width of each step it
automatically knows how long the
staircase is going to
be
and here our um
this is our
settings
right
so right now desired number of steps is
19 so this is how many steps we want and
actual thread depth is 25 so it's only
25 centimeters really
maybe that's fine um
i like doing 28 centimeters for for for
the threads but this is a pretty small
house so 25 is okay and then it
automatically
automatically calculates
what's going to be the riser height so
that's one point
sorry that's 18 centimeters which is
fine
uh 18 is okay
so usually it's 17.5 but again this is a
small house so when we just do a regular
straight staircase it's it's pretty
straightforward right we just
i can say run is
location of the line is on the left hand
side of the run and i can just oops
not the left hand side right hand side
run right
from here
to here bam that's it that's that's a
staircase
i can even show it to you here
no i can't i need a section
to be able to show you
um can we do a section no we can't while
we are
while we are running the staircase the
stair tool
so let me open up the building a bit so
that you can see better what what's
going on
so again stair
cancel
ground floor
so
notice how that menu popped up that was
because i was in 3d view instead i will
create a ground floor
the staircase and ground floor view so
then it won't even ask me any questions
so it's there from here to ah run on the
right
from here to here
bam
just creates a staircase so there's no
opening and so on but that's fine that's
that's something that we will
we will easily
easily fix
okay
so that is a very
simple staircase without any risers
without sorry without any landings
without anything like that so let me
delete it and instead let's see other
variations of the staircase that we can
do we can do full step spiral
so that's that was the straight
staircase we can do a full step spiral
which is basically just
there we go
here it fits
right so it just generates a spiral
staircase nothing nothing fancy about it
um
not really sure
how
how it can be used in this particular
project because it eats up so much space
but it is there
then you have center and spiral uh which
is basically
you describe the center point
you and then you describe the end point
and you can do
you know you you do the spiral staircase
so it looks the same but
if i were to repeat it and if i were to
say
um something like
this
and then
repeat it again
oh my god this is
annoying
ah let's just do it this way repeat it
again and see something like this
bam or
fine
oh my god
i can't fit it properly so i'm
struggling with it let's let's try it
again
uh that's going to be our center point
and we will start from here
half a turn
like that
and then
this is going to be our center point we
will start from here
and another half a turn so it's going to
make this kind of a this kind of a
staircase
which uh yep
it is how it is it looks how it looks i
know but
um let me just delete it so that you
don't need to look at it
uh automatically
whatever
okay
so then we have l form staircase which
is
quite
quite convenient but it's basically just
drag and drop and then once you drag it
dragged and dropped it you will need to
align it with with the walls of course
so to align you can either rotate it so
you select the tool or the thing and you
rotate it
like that
right
that's super super simple or or there is
an option for aligning
a line
so it's going to ask you to give it a
reference line so let's see this line
and it's going to ask you to give it a
alignment line so this line here let's
see
or that yeah there we go so first it's
the alignment line and then there's the
reference line and it's just going to
snap to snap to place
also kind of kind of useful uh
especially in these kind of uh kind of
houses because then you can
um
move through
move below the the staircase
so that might be something that you
would like to look into
um last one that i am going to cover is
the
u-shape
winder i guess
uh so it's basically this kind of
staircase
right again it this one is just drag and
drop and again i will just use align
tool click
click to just snap it to place
easy
um
right
so that's uh that's the staircases uh
the default staircases rather so then
you have the possibility to make your
own uh well not make your own but draw
your own staircase which i really
enjoy
so you can create runs
landings
and support systems which we don't care
about so run
is basically
let's say i want
my first run to be
only two meters long
and i want my second run
to be
let's take let's say it starts from here
and goes um
on the left hand side and goes until
let's see only for a meter like that
and then i have my third run which is on
the right so you keep switching between
left right level light to goes like so
it's no problem it's going to do it
right it's it's not going to
be tricky at all uh it's going to
automatically connect the staircases
with the runs
sometimes it doesn't
so if it doesn't let's see if if there
is a disconnect between
this
let me show you here
in 3d as well if there is a disconnect
between this run and this run
right
i can
draw a landing
either by hand or by specifying
that yo please connect
this
this and this
right
so just click click and it will connect
them with a run or if i want a fancy
some sort of fancy shape for for my my
landing
then i can create a sketch
create a sketch
and then just draw it out so i will just
say
i want my landing to be a beautiful
little
form
like
this
come on
snap
there we go
bam
just make sure that it's a closed uh
holy line
hit apply
bam that's that's your that's your
landing and right now it's not tied to
your stairs so you would need to
actually
uh
change the relative height of it so that
it is indeed
tied
with with the steps so um you can do
that by calculating
um
the the height of each step and kind of
getting the the correct
value for it
i think like let's say
2500 here apply
yeah that's close enough
that's close enough
so you end up with this kind of a weird
run where it may it does make mistakes
here
uh it doesn't feel it
fill it in or anything like that but
it is a possibility
let me delete that
um yeah that's that's about it in in
terms of stairs so let me just create a
super simple one right now
just a
straight staircase
um and here
when i'm going to be creating it i'll
just go through the
go through the the settings and here i
kind of want to do let's see
what kind of monolithic staircase how
does that look like
yeah so i i do
like the monolithic staircase type
because it's super simple right
it does exactly what i want it to do
it's it's a super simple staircase so
let's let's do it and i'll just do a
straight line for it
so let's see a person who walks in
um
hangs his or her coat and then is a
staircase waiting for them
uh on this side so i just want to give
them like 1.5 let's say mirrors of space
to move
uh 1.5 there we go space to move uh
along so so that there is like a
there's no awkward awkward moments here
uh the width of the staircase is one
mirror um i can change it here if i want
to but i think for something like this
one meter is a okay there's no railing
but
you can add railing
uh to the staircase
um
by just clicking this this button
railing
uh where you kind of choose what kind of
type of railing you want
um
[Music]
i don't know what's default
let's see
ma'am
hello railing
that's weird let me just accept
this ah okay so it it did create railing
once i have accepted the staircase so
this kind of railing is super ugly and i
don't like it
so if if you don't want the railing you
can always
delete it
straight up
just delete it
that fixes your
your problem of not having a nice
railing but now you have another problem
which is people falling down your stairs
so to fix it let's say uh i will just
make a a wall here right
for for the staircase i'll just make a
wall i'll just put it in the wall
the gallery owner needs a wall either
way so might as well do it for them
so i will
create a wall
and it's not going to be a curtain wall
it's going to be an interior wall uh one
three eight millimeter seems fine
uh that's a partitioning wall and just
create one here uh
that is not going to be a center line i
don't i can't have it as a center line
finish face exterior probably
nope i was wrong
finish face interior
like that
so you always kind of mess around with
the alignment alignment of the walls
so i think that
and then that
should be a okay
enter
so we have this kind of a
weird awkward interior wall here but we
will fix it by just selecting it holding
down the control key selecting both of
them
um and then just saying top constraint
is up to
the first floor and top offset is
minus 150.
the reason why it's minus 150 is because
of the
thickness of the floor slab
okay great
now we have
now now we have some
some walls here and i will probably
just add
architecture door just because i
want to i'll just add a door here
like that
because you kind of want to
use up the space
below the
the staircase for storage
so we have that and that is uh good
enough for
or for paintings to hang and you kind of
just you're you're not losing uh surface
area for the gallery
and that's that's the key i guess
um
okay
so now
one last thing
just one last thing is that the
staircases uh
they don't go anywhere right once they
reach the second floor they you just
bump your head
or the first floor you just bump your
head
uh we need to make a hole in the
first floor to let the staircase in
and to do that i will just
go to first floor
right here
i can see that the staircase ends here
that's perfect
uh and i will create a shaft opening
so i can either create a shaft opening
or i can change the boundary of the
floor itself
let me show you both variations on how
to do it so let's say the first
variation is changing the boundary of
the floor
right
so actually changing it in this section
sometimes it's kind of hard to select
the floor slab
so i'll just do it in 3d view selecting
the floor slab there and then continue
working in the plan view
so we are going to change the boundary
of this floor slab so if i click on edit
boundary
right here
i can
draw
lines so the pink line here is the
boundary of our floor
but if i let's say take a let's go for a
circle circle tool and just draw out a
circle right in the middle of the
boundary and hit accept
um
[Music]
this is
what's going to happen right it's going
to make a hole uh off of that circle so
let me come back here
or rather undo ctrl z
um and ctrl z once more to
undo the the circle and instead let me
draw out
the opening for the staircase
so this is 3.5 meters
right
the ceiling height is 3.5 meters so that
means if
if we kind of climb up to the half of
the stairs
it's 1.75
meters of of clearance so that's not
good that means we need
um
at least
three more steps
uh for for the clearance to be
okay so that we don't bump our heads so
i'm
guessing if this is the middle
if this line if it's the middle of the
staircase i'm guessing up until here we
need an opening
so let me just and that's good that we
have an arrow just kind of showing us
that um so let me just grab a line tool
and just draw
one
two
three
four
five
just kind of clicking five times to draw
this rectangle hitting accept
would you like walls that go up to this
floor level to attach to its bottom
would you like walls
that go up
to this floor's level to attach to its
bottom
nah don't attach don't don't don't care
don't care
um
and yeah we have our opening now
right with with our steps
there is
a little bit of a gap there why is there
a gap there
ah that's because of the discrepancy of
of the riser height so it couldn't fit
perfectly
but
oh or maybe it could
no it could because this height is the
same as this height okay so that's
sorry that that was my bad it's all good
it's all good
so we have
an opening for our staircase the problem
now is you know and you kind of continue
working on it the problem now is that
you can fall down here right in the in
the into this hole so we need to build
up
some
some walls
yeah sure save project always save your
projects by the way so we need to build
up some walls
from here to here
to maybe here
just like that
enter
and then i'm just going to modify
select these two walls holding down the
control key and say that it's actually
connected to the second floor and the
top offset is again -150
apply
perfect
so now
if i make a section through the stair
steps
steps
i can see
you know how exactly this whole thing
works
right
so we're we're making progress right so
we can access the first floor and now we
have access to the
to the second floor
and then
of course you would need to figure out a
way of how to access the third floor
and all of that good stuff
it would probably be some sort of uh
actually let me
let me just show you just so that you
uh
get a sense of of how i'm i'm thinking
when i'm doing these things
so you arrive here right that's that's
your arrival point in the second floor
in the first floor sorry from the ground
floor uh so that's your arrival point
and then you choose to either go up
again or to go into
this space right so that means it makes
sense uh to have a staircase winding
around here
right
doing a u-shaped wind here so i'll
create a stair
uh cast in place there moletics there
that's perfect and i will give it a
first run after one meter
i'll give it the first run
of four steps
right here so there is like a gap
right here
then i will give it
uh
four more steps here fail to generate
automatic landing layout that's fine
we'll just move uh these steps away a
little bit and it will generate the
landing
and then the rest is going to be
generated here
can't make stair stairs
uh
why
cancel
cool
welcome to revit
okay we try again
steps
this time um
let's let's say
only three steps here two three no
uh a bit closer
three steps here
then
four steps here
and then the remaining ones are
here
can't make stairs
why
why are you complaining about this
cancel
okay let me
do
let me not snap to this
edge here maybe it's it doesn't like it
and instead snap to
like align it with these steps here
like that
maybe that's yeah okay so that works uh
just try until it works
that's that's the answer
um
yeah and that is basically it then then
i just hit accept like finish editing
bam it creates these railings which we
just get rid of
like that and now we have our steps to
the second floor and the second floor
also doesn't have a hole in it right so
we need to create a hole for or the
second floor
uh to do that i will actually show you
the other way of how to do it with the
shaft so i will go to my second floor
that's great
that's where the steps are and i will
create a shaft opening
so i clicked on the shaft option there
and the shaft opening basically just
asks me to draw a boundary line
again
so i'm just drawing a line
probably something like that
yeah let's yolo it
something like that
accept
bam
we have our opening and yep the shaft
just ate up the
floor above as well so we need to change
uh the height of the shaft and the cool
thing about is is that with the shaft
tool you can just kind of go to 3d and
just drag it down
you know so that it doesn't reach
the that floor and you're you're you're
good to go
so you just kind of drag down the top
face of the shaft
um that's it about and of course you
would need to add the walls there and
then so on and kind of
mess around with the railing here
uh perhaps i shouldn't have deleted the
railing there but
who cares um
right
so we covered walls we covered glazing
curtain systems curtain panels
we cover doors windows
uh columns are boring um architectural
column you can just
kind of place a column anywhere you want
bam
there's a column
for some reason there's two
never mind there's only one so you can
place columns but i don't think you will
need any columns in this kind of a
building
you have ceilings we don't care about
ceilings floors okay we have
done all of this all of this
grid is done
[Music]
super okay we are done with this part of
the tutorial next time i will show you
how to actually get
drawings out you know it's going to be
the final tutorial so
everything that
that i've missed i will
show you how to do it
um
how do i say it get to work so to begin
we have covered walls doors windows all
of that good stuff
and the only thing left is
furniture and i'm not going to be
detailing this this project
to
you know to its full potential so to say
uh this is just for me to show you um
the different components so it's not
going to be
in my case it's not going to be a
finished project but for you as students
i
expect you
to
kind of do and do a full project
um
right so let's begin
the thing is
that with
revit 2021
uh there are
there isn't a lot of
objects or a lot of furniture pieces
that you can natively
get into your project if i go here to
component
right if i click on this component icon
i can see here that there are some desks
that i can choose from there's a parking
space
some trees
and that's basically it that that's
basically it uh from from the default
um
like default library
so it's not
it's far from being a big library
uh so how do you get more stuff in here
um well there is this button here called
load family
if you press it it will open up a
browser for you a file browser and from
here you
if you have an older version of revit
you would be able to choose
a furniture piece or or like you would
be be able to navigate through the
library of furniture pieces
uh but here it's just structural precast
and some some weird stuff so
i don't have anything here so how do you
get
a library in revit 2021
how do you get a library in here well
you need to go to let me first escape
out of this tool there we go and you
need to go to
insert
and click on load family
and those of you who are working on the
school's computers i will be able to i
believe you will find the library
already installed but those of you who
are working from home
this is what you need to do especially
with the new revit
click on get autodesk content
right here
which will open up
you can see it there we go it will open
up a browser page uh for you
uh where you can get where you can
download
uh the the
content so this is the the library of
furniture and whatnot um and that kind
of content is
split
into different regions so english united
states english united kingdom and if we
scroll down far far down
you will see english sweden
right and here there there are these uh
uh swedish libraries which you can
install but there are only 15 megabytes
which tells me that there's not a lot of
stuff in there right so instead what i'm
going to do
i'm going to actually download the
english united states metric libraries
which is 1.2 gigabytes right much larger
so that means much more stuff for me to
play with so i'll click on this
and it will immediately start
downloading
if it doesn't you might need to sign in
but
it seems like i haven't signed in so it
should be fine right so i'll wait for it
to
finish downloading uh install it and
then we will take a look at
[Music]
how to get them into your file so just a
second
actually
actually to save time
while it's downloading i will be messing
around with
with the furniture here
so
with the furniture that i have so in
architecture tab i'll click on the
component tab and i'll see
yeah sure this desk uh pretty ugly one
but who cares
basically adding a disk is just as easy
as going to let's see the ground floor
zooming in
and
hello oh right uh so if you change views
it will
it it will ask you to to run the command
again so i'll click on component desk
and here i just
can click and place the desk
uh
okay so it's thinking let's hope it's
not gonna crash it didn't so okay so we
we have a desk in here and i can place
another one if i want to
whatever
so i have two desks here if i check it
in 3d view i can see those two desks
being displayed here even being cut one
of them is being cut so
let me go back to the ground floor
delete one of those desks
and this one
what can you do with it well you can
move it around of course
you can rotate it so that's the rotate
button right here
right
so
from here
to here
you can rotate it let me undo that
and you can align it as well so this
desk
i will click on the alignment tool
choose let's see this wall here
this disk
line here and it's going to snap in
place it's going to be aligned so that
means now i can kind of move it
okay let me escape out there we go now i
can move it and place it properly
on my
inside of my building
uh let's see it in 3d yeah that's how it
is um if you don't see a line here
um just like i don't uh that means your
desk is clipping into it's it's being
pushed into the wall a little bit
that's fine
what we can do is in ground floor we
just move it slightly away from the wall
one
just slightly there we go 10 centimeters
that's maybe a little bit too much
i zoomed in too far so now we need to
wait for it to
do its
thing i don't know what it's doing but
yeah there we go so here now once i
selected it i can see the dimension here
saying a hundred millimeters i can
change this to 50
right so it's only five centimeters away
from the wall
perfect
if i
go to 3d view i can now see that that
line is present
oh that's an ugly desk let me just
delete it
okay
is it done yet
yes it is okay so once you have
downloaded the exe file i'll just run it
so it's opening it up
revit is famous for being super slow and
installing stuff but it seems to be
doing the trick let me hit extract
and it should be
yeah it's fine so it's now it's
extracting all of the
material that i have downloaded
uh
taking super long but
come on come on
not not the best thing for for a
tutorial to wait for things to extract
but
who cares it's just like 15 seconds 20
seconds
a minute maybe
perfect time for a coffee break
um while it's extracting actually it
should be already loading in the
the files and
let me just make sure
2021 autodesk folder okay so it should
be extracting into the correct folder so
let me jump back to ground floor
go to
architecture tab component
and click on load family
here
and let me find english not english
imperial but english
oh yeah there we go so there's now a lot
of folders in here which is great
and they are being
some files could not be created please
close all applications or between this
and restart this installation yeah sure
so basically what it's saying is you
shouldn't be running
you shouldn't be loading in the
libraries
while you are extracting the libraries
we don't care we have
quite a few already installed this is
going to be enough
to
get the point across
so let me repeat that step
just to make sure that you all follow
i clicked on
components
icon and then clicked on load family and
here i'm in english imperial library so
i just moved up one folder
and found my english
regular english folder
which is metric and here we have
different kinds of windows for instance
you know new kinds of windows that you
didn't see before
and also we have
furniture
furniture there we go furniture system
or furniture so let me jump to furniture
let me see what kind of tables it has so
once i click on one i can see the
uh a preview of it so round rectangular
um still not that great
but a bit a little bit better than what
we had before
so for instance this round table i'll
hit open
and nothing happens
oh never mind it all immediately loads
it in and now i can place it right
so
once i've pasted it and let me escape
out of out of everything
and even delete this this
table altogether if now i go to
components tab i can see that now this
table with all of this variations
is
loaded in to the project right so now i
can use it anytime i want right just
choose it and place it
okay so just i mean on your own time you
can
investigate what kind of stuff there is
and what kind of families you can load
in but it's mostly tables beds
um
[Music]
right different kinds of beds
seating
right different kinds of chairs
even carbs just here
right that
and then if we
take a closer look to to all of the
folders in the library
we can see that there's even curtain
wall panels different types of curtain
wall panels different types of columns
[Music]
different types of
different stuff
so
one thing that i'm interested in is
windows for instance because before we
had to
work with pretty
default you know pretty regular windows
so if i
escape out
if i have let's say
let me look at the 3d model
where could i add a window by the way
this is
this is complete
garbage you can't access this area right
here so my staircase is completely like
nonsense uh it's it's it's a bad
staircase
i should probably fix it
yeah for pedagogical purposes i will be
fixing the staircase sorry i can't can't
have that in the tutorial so that's uh
my first floor
let me jump in there
uh this staircase blocks off entrance to
the
to the balcony so i'll just delete it
and instead let me just quickly
stare
there we go
let me just from here to here four steps
that's perfect and then from here
to here all remaining steps
that's uh can't make stairs that's cool
uh let me try again escape or not escape
just create a landing
um let's say from here
to here
there we go now it's fine
um i'll hit accept
i'll probably change the oh no it is a
monolithic run but it does have the
um
much more call it the the the railing
so let me jump to a 3d view
get rid of the railing that it's not in
the way
um i would need to fix a bunch of stuff
here but that that is okay
um
or maybe we keep the railing well
either way first floor
there's enough of a gap for here to to
walk through that's fine and now we have
a gap here to actually access the
balcony
i believe in the second floor we need to
yeah
on the second floor we actually need
um an opening here so uh to to access to
be able to access the second floor now
from the staircase so i will be
either adding a new shaft opening or
maybe in this case i will change i will
delete the shaft opening altogether
and i will change the
the boundary of the floor slab here
so to do that let in in 3d view let me
just select the
the floor slab oop
this one the floor slab in question
uh let me go to the first floor
uh nope that's in the second floor there
we go
and let me click on edit boundary
right here
wait for it to
figure it figure out what i want and
here i will just draw a few lines so
from here to here
and i think up until here should be
enough
so that's going to be my opening which
means that this line and this line
like this line segment and this line
segment shouldn't be there
so i will be
uh using
either uh
no wait pick walls is bad
just a second oh there we go i will be
using trim extend to corner uh tool
right here
so i'll select this line first and then
this line
so now they get
like trimmed together
and then this line and this line and
also they get trimmed together i'll hit
accept would you like walls to go i
don't attach don't care
now i have a proper opening in 3d view
if i take a look at it and this is how
it looks i think that's fine
so now we can move up and we actually do
have a
possibility for an entrance which i am
going to create
so
let's
continue uh let's jump into
second floor
oh wait no sorry first floor let's jump
into first floor and add the door here
so to add the door you click on the door
tool and actually
why don't we find a different kind of a
door i assume the library that we
downloaded should contain different
doors so load family
go up from the tables from furniture and
let's see
dddd stands for doors
doors there we go doors
double click oh that's a lot of doors
um
curtain wall double glass door that's
nice
it's a simple one
single panel door commercial doors
and nothing too
too nice here maybe we can just do
curtain wall single glass
you know regular doorway
only that is in glass hit open
it gets loaded in some of all of the
families cannot be loaded
what
that's weird i am in the doors
doors family
okay you must choose family files of the
category doors do you want to re retry
loading a new set of oh right okay
so this is
this is important
this is important so notice how the name
says m
door curtain wall single glass curtain
wall is the key thing here so that means
that this door belongs to a system of a
curtain wall rather than
a door system um remember back in
the previous tutorial i did a curtain
wall
so this is a way of how you can add a
door into the curtain wall so this
family
uh doesn't doesn't work so instead we
need
[Music]
like a regular door
like that
um let's just find one that's
good enough
so all of these are curtain wall doors
right
um
double
no no
i shouldn't be picky
yeah sure panel would yeah whatever i'll
just use that one
it's it's not the prettiest but it will
do i'll hit open
now it it actually works i hit ok
sure save the project whatever
and now i'm able to add that particular
door and it even has different
types here
for me to choose from right
so i'll choose the
let's say 2.1 meters by 80 centimeters
something like that
opens up outwards
like that
that's it
so we have our door uh
inserted right if i take a look at it in
3d
that's not the door that i want
so i will just simply select it
scroll down here
oh and and just choose the
interior single
four panel wooden door type right so i
just switched the door type
so now we're gucci
um let's jump to first floor and add the
window just like we added the door and
let's add a super ugly window so let me
go to the window tool load family
jump back
find windows there we go and let me just
find a weird one
oh my god this is a no
um let's just find a regular one so it's
it's the types of windows just like
doors it's not like you can add any type
of window to any type of geometry
uh you will need to
fiddle a little bit with it until you
you become
comfortable i will add
oh perfect yeah that that's excellent
that's
that's exactly the window that i wanted
to add i'll hit open
it's going to load it in and now i can
just add it i'll just add it in here
bam
like that
let me check it in 3d view that's
that's how it looks like
i believe i will change the sill height
to a little bit higher
to to be a little bit higher so i'll
just change it to 1 meter 200
millimeters
yeah
yeah sounds about right or rather looks
about right
horrible anyway so that's how you add uh
custom custom stuff to your your
geometries uh last thing that i'm going
to do since this is a gallery i should
probably add wind
not windows i should probably add like
paintings and stuff uh so
i will
family
load in family
and where could i find paintings
plumbing profiles railings
furniture probably furniture right
yeah probably furniture so furniture
that's mirror
beds storage tables
there's no painting here huh
oh my god so it's going to take me a
while to
to find it
but we can find
we can use a cabinet
like shelving and place it there at
least so i'll do that instead
i know for a fact that there are
paintings here uh in in this library
it's just that finding them
you know since i don't do it that often
i don't remember where they are so
instead i'll add a shelf there
um i really hope that i can change the
width of the shelf we will see
um i'll hit open
and probably need to do that in the
ground floor right
yeah
like that and i will add i'll be adding
a shelf right here
so first let me
place it
escape
there we go so now it's placed and let's
see if we can edit type and
yeah super so we can edit the
[Music]
the the shelf width and height and so on
that that's that's great that's what we
want
um so let's make it proper
i will
grab the 3d view
like that and i will dock it to the side
like that
perfect just so that i can constantly
see
you know
the the shelf itself and there's my
shelf
just standing there
so what i want to do is i want to make a
different kind of section so let me move
this
section plane right here
and instead let me move this section
plane inwards even more
uh maybe that's a little bit too much
a little bit out oops that's the wrong
one
bam
okay that's good so now we see our
shelf
just
standing there
i will align it
so i will select it
click on the align tool
from
to this edge from this edge
just line it like that and we have our
shelf
i'll click on modify
select it
and now we can actually add a type and
let's just hope that it it works right
so depth
of the shelf
uh let's say
500 millimeters
let apply
okay that that works i will move it to
to the correct position
just in a second
height so i know that the height between
the floors the the
the ground floor is 3.5 meters minus
the floor slab so it's actually
two eight five zero millimeters that's
the height of the shelf it apply
there we go that's good that's good
and for width
let's do a three meter shelf
apply
maybe that's a bit too much let's do a
two meter shelf
yeah that's that's good enough
uh and then i will just simply
reposition it
and snap it in place and now i have a
shelf here
right
to put some stuff in
um right so that's how you add furniture
uh pretty pretty simple
now once once you've done that
once you've added uh
added furniture added all of the cool
stuff that you want to have in your in
your building
it's
around time that we actually start
working with the graphics and extracting
nice graphics from your 3d model right
so how do we how do we go about it well
first of all i want to
i want to make sure that every view that
i have
actually has a proper
um
proper depth if that makes sense so i
will be going through actually now i
don't need 3d view anymore uh i will be
going through every gra every floor and
just checking if the depth is proper
so here that seems fine
that's our ground floor
first floor
we see the balcony
and that seems fine second floor
seems okay
third floor
wait second floor
should see the balcony here right on on
the on the second floor and we don't so
if if that happens
uh what you do is without having
anything selected you go here on the
left hand side and you find
view range
option
view range and you click on edit
that view range
and here you will you will have this
pop-up where you can change
uh
how deep do you see from that particular
floor
and it's also at what height do you cut
but i don't change that
uh so level i will just say i want to
see all the way down to ground floor
hit apply
hit okay and now we see the balcony
same thing for the third floor
um where is it
view range
up to the ground floor apply
okay
there we go
fourth floor
floor actually does have
oh wait we don't need four floor fourth
floor is going to be our roof uh so we
don't care about the fourth floor
all right so we have
all of the views done
uh
like that that we need and now it's all
about filling in right all about making
hatches creating hatches and
one thing that i would probably do
before
before making it pretty or making it
nicer i guess
i will go to sheets
here
remember in rhino you have layouts so
here layouts are called sheets and i
will create
create a sheet
for every
view that i'm going to have
so i will right click
on the sheets
and choose new sheet
click there and you can see that it asks
me for a title block and by default it's
set to a1 metric and no we will be using
a3 and we don't have one right but
you're in luck because i have created
one for you to use so
on the course website
uh lth digitalwordpress.com
15
[Music]
scroll scroll scroll scroll
you can download layout sheet template
in revit family format
this one right here or if this one
doesn't work for you then you will be
able to download the old version where
you will need to change the
the title but that's
easy
an easy fix
so you download this one
just download
there we go
have it here
paste it here oh i already have had it
here
um and i will
now load it in once it's downloaded i'll
click on load i'll go to desktop
and i have my aada15 sheet here hit open
hit okay
there it is right so now if i expand it
i can see that it's a0101
unnamed
sheet that's fine we will be naming them
in just a second
so how do you get
a drawing
into
the
sheet
well you do that by
just
for instance ground floor by just
clicking and dragging in the drawing
into the sheet
click drag
bam
uh
where is it oh yeah
it's going to ask you for position click
again
there it is
now it's inside of the sheet
good enough
good enough for now
um i wonder if we can
get rid of the
ground floor title block
i'll need to investigate
so
[Music]
here in in in this particular view
you are able to
kind of either crop
the view or
uh change the visuals of this particular
view uh i know that that's a not a
tongue twister but
just
my brain is slow today
basically you can adjust the graphics of
this particular drawing in
just to be in this sheet
first things first
since i have a title block i don't need
this
[Music]
this title right here
ground floor 1 to 100
with numeration
so i will select it
and i will actually
i believe it's in edit type right yes so
once you select it you go to edit type
right like right here and you untick
show extension line
and you
where it says show title you
say no
and that should be yeah that should be
that
so now it's done hit okay
you're good with that
now for this particular
view it's too big right it doesn't fit
in your
in your drawing so what do you do well
here
on once you have selected it on the
[Music]
left hand side
you can find
a tab called extends and a tick mark
box called or check box called crop view
if you
select crop view and also if you select
crop region visible
you'll be able to
[Music]
to crop
to crop the view
yeah for the lack of a better word so
let's see how how that how that works i
don't think you can crop the view in the
sheet
which which is
which kind of sucks
but once you have those two tick marks
and you go back to your ground floor
view
this rectangle will appear and then here
in your ground floor plan
you're able you you will be able to move
this box
that the sides of this box around until
everything kind of fits nicely and then
if you look at your sheet again
this is how it looks
right so i can see that i need to crop
it even further so actually i'll just go
to ground floor again and crop it even
further
perhaps there is a better way of doing
it
but
i don't know uh i i always used this
this method and it seems to work
so yeah
you end up with having this this kind of
a view and this is 1 to 100 scale
right uh this particular view is at the
scale of one to a hundred how do i know
well when i select the view
and i scroll up here i can see view
scale is one to a hundred if i change
this to one to five hundred hit apply
uh it's right here right so that's now
one to five hundred you can see that the
axes
don't scale
uh which is
it's natural it they don't they
shouldn't scale
uh with the view
there we go so we have our
ground floor plan placed in inside of a
sheet that's great and now there's
just a few more things to fix here
before we move on to our other plans
so
drawing name
i wonder why is this not
okay so
how do you change things here drawing
scale of course you don't need to change
it's already kind of reading what kind
of a
scale you were working in
but for instance drawing name and
author's information you do need to
insert right so for drawing name i will
just click once
and click once more it's not a double
click if you double click it it's bad
so it's click and then click again
um
and i'll just say
ground
floor
plan
plus 0.000
right
it should be plus minus but i don't care
um and then for
uh
for the
for my own name it's just
there we go my own name
um that's it right
and you can see that the sheets
automatically update the name here
pops up ground floor plan plus
0.000 altitude okay so now we need to
repeat this
for every
floor for every section and for every
elevation and the 3d view as well
um
i will do this
a few more times
and i will do this faster just
so that you can kind of
see the process a few more times and
then kind of
hopefully it will help you troubleshoot
so
let's begin so i'll create a new sheet
uh it's already present here since i
loaded it in
like that i will drag in first floor
bam like that i will position it
like that i will go to my first floor
and here i'll scroll down
check mark crop view crop region visible
i'll crop it to
barely fit
like that
great
so that's now cropped
i'll jump back to my
sheet that's going to fit properly i'll
just position it
drawing name i will change the drawing
name to first
floor
plan
plus
3.5000 or five zero zero
um my name is there it remembers that's
good yeah that's done
all right
then let's do one for a section and one
for elevation and one for 3d
so i will
create so that's going to be for section
new sheet that's going to be for
elevation
new sheet that's going to be for 3d
all right so let me grab um
i don't care which section section one
sure
i'll just grab section one here
place it
uh that's fine
i'll grab
for for this sheet i will grab elevation
uh let's go for street elevation
edit
bam
that's done
and for this sheet i will grab the 3d
view
wait uh
no that's the section
that's the elevation okay sure this one
is going to be the 3d view
bam
click
okay so there's a bunch of stuff that
i'll need to fix in all three of them so
first off um elevation
there's uh you
[Laughter]
you you uh
quite quite a few
uh quite a few
ugly bits but
i think we will manage
so let me first position it
something like that seems to be okay let
me check the street elevation
um i will just actually drag this uh to
be wider so our street elevation already
has this uh all of this incorporated
that this cropping box which is super
great
um and let me just drag these out
i can't drag them more huh
so they get locked for some reason
that's fine
um
and let me oh my god come on just just
let me
i just want to select there we go okay
i managed to select the the last
mark
and for some reason other
marks
just disappeared i don't know why
that's super weird it shouldn't happen
so we try it again
yay
can we unlock this
so
this lock means that
oh understood okay so
these locks mean that if i move
uh for instance this
um single sheet here
see how all others move
that's because they are locked together
right so that that's what this lock
means it's actually a pretty useful
thing so
the reason why the those disappeared was
because once i select this
zoomed into too close now it's
calculating
if i select this
bottom markup
i can see that it's locked
with the dashed line i can see that it's
actually locked to
the ends of all other floors and i don't
want that so what i'm going to do is
actually instead of unlocking it i will
tick mark here
to have it on both sides i will tick
mark untick here
you barely can see it it's it's right
here that that rectangle i will untick
here to to hide that side and now i will
indeed move
the side out so that it fits
properly here once everything is aligned
i believe all of them get locked
together
which is absolutely fine this one is a
little bit out of bounds so let me just
move it back in
so this is how it looks
let me check check it in 3d not in 3d in
the sheet
it seems to be fitting quite properly
the section plane the section line is a
little bit out of bounds so let me fix
that
street elevation
you
are
way too close
or way too far
be here
and also i don't want this line running
through the middle of my drawing so i'll
just move it
like so
like that
and like that perfect okay so that is
done and maybe even i will get the
cropping rectangle and i'll move it
slightly in
like that
just to clean it up a bit
um
yeah let's see let's see let's see
how it looks this is how it looks i
think that's okay
not great not terrible just okay
um but
i think this is this is something that
we can continue on working with
so that's our facade um let me rename
this
street
assad
yep
let me jump into this section and
actually immediately i'll rename this
section to
section aaa
like that
notice how the section is uh
filled in uh while the all other
drawings are not that's because if i
take a look at the section um and i
believe it's section one right
it is filled in here and
this is just
the graphics settings right so i can
change this to hidden line and now it's
not filled in and if i now take a look
at it in the
[Music]
sheet i keep wanting to say uh
i now forgot the other one i keep
wanting to see layout
rather than sheet
um
now it's not filled right so it's it's
graphic settings that you want to change
if if there's a fill and you don't want
to see a fill
so that's our section
nothing
very fancy happening here and it's
actually pretty damn close to being
fine
let me see if i can add more stuff if i
can see more stuff within this section
okay so there's the surrounding building
right there
and can i see the one on the other side
of the street yes i can so i will just
do something like this just to get
the section of the street and the the
section of the next door building
um
jump back to section aa this is how it
looks
almost fits
i say i'd say i'd say almost fits
um
do we just do it like that
ah come on
by the way you can use arrow keys to
kind of move it around
so yeah okay good it fits
the dashed lines go out of bounds but we
don't care about those dashed lines so
that's fine and the section line as
always is super obnoxious and i will be
fixing it
map
and
just move that one in here
uh until here
clipping plane
up
like that
flipping plane come on come on just give
me give me give me like that there we go
okay so that is done that's our section
a a uh for now
and then the last one is the 3d view
which we will kind of revisit in just a
second right now it's still well
actually let's let's uh let's let's make
it nice
so that's in 3d
i will just
move my clipping box here
[Music]
that's fine
i think that's something like that is
kind of kind of neat
let's see if we can add some more
bizarres here
that's nice
i think that that that looks okay
um let's
see uh is it possible for me to hide
this in this view i believe it is if i
delete it yeah it's going to
um to delete the floor plans as well
which i don't want to do at all so
instead i will figure out a way of how
to hide it
which is i believe this button right
here hide in view
hide
category or hide elements hide elements
there we go let's see if it actually
translates to our 3d sheet here it does
okay great so let us hide a bunch of
stuff in in this 3d view so that it's
not
obnoxious
um
with information so that all of that
actually
hide
in view
hide elements okay that's good can i
hide this
yes i can super okay
so these are hidden
the shadows are a bit funky but that
that's okay
this is how it looks uh let's take a
look at it in 3d
yeah sure not 3d sorry in the sheet
bam
that looks actually good that that looks
fine
i'll just place it here
my graphics card is
crying a bit but that's
that's normal
um
and yeah let's just name it um
3d
exonometric
[Music]
3d axonometric uh drawing scale there is
no scale for an axonometric drawing so
of course it's going to be empty
okay
that is done right that is that is okay
that's done we are ready to move forward
and the next thing that we're going to
do is drink some coffee
delicious
and jump to our ground floor plan
the sheet of ground floor plan
and we will change
the
display settings
here for this sheet so
for instance
let's start with a simple super simple
example
i want
the walls here
to be filled in black right
so how do i do that well the thing is
that in
revit
everything
that you do
um every geometry belongs to a certain
category as i mentioned before and all
of that geometry is going to be
it within that category category is
going to be shown in a certain way
once you just look at it and once you
look at a cut of it right so how do you
change it how do you change the the
visuals
well you go to the view tab
here in the top
and you choose visibility and graphics
so these are visibility and graphics
settings right for that particular view
in this case this sheet right here
visibility and graphics
and here it's a pretty
big
table
where you can change different different
aspects of your
of your graphics right so basically how
do you show air terminals how do you
show areas how do you show ceilings how
do you show columns and and so on
all of that is being treated by this
table
um
one important
one important note is that
you have two
big
sides here not sides two big columns
here one is projection surface this is
where you just look at the element
and the other one is cut
which means how would it show you a
section of that particular element so in
case of
maybe that's the fastest way to do it is
just to show you with wall so i just
scroll down to walls
and i will say when i cut
the walls
the lines
of the cut
so i'll click on override here
the lines of the cut
should be solid
should have red color
and should be
pretty damn thick
maybe even thicker let's go for 16 who
cares hit ok
hit apply
and nothing changes
how come
is it because i'm in the sheet
sorry
technical difficulties please please
hold visibility on graphics
walls
solid red
16
okay apply
ah okay apparently you need to change it
not in the sheet but rather in the
um
in the floor plan itself
and then it should show up
yeah then it's going to show up in the
sheet so as you can see 16 is a little
bit thick
uh let's jump back and let's actually
jump back to ground floor plan and
actually change the the
graphics here so i will click on
visibility graphics and go back to walls
and actually i do want my wall cut
to be
solid
a solid line but it should be black
and the weight should be
less like five or something
yeah that that seems good right
so so we end up with these these this
kind of cut and then for the pattern i
will say overwrite
and you you have the possibility to have
two patterns but i would strongly
suggest you not having two patterns you
know one laid on top of the other
foreground background instead just work
with the background pattern
for now
so for pattern i will also see solid
fill and i'll say
yeah again black
hit okay
hit apply
that's that's that right
so what else can we change here in in
the plan
uh plan view well the surrounding
buildings and the surrounding uh
uh street and so on uh all of them are
white and actually i wanted to kind of
change not to change
to
differentiate between the inside
of this building and everything else the
outside so remember right at the start
of the course we have imported
the surrounding geometry the site
3d model as a generic model so now i
will find
this generic model type here
generic models
right here and
i will say
that when we cut the generic models
it should still have a pretty thick
solid line right so solid line black
color
weight
again five
oh yeah hit apply forgot so now it it
kind of gives us a bolder line where it
cuts
and then for patterns
uh for the cut pattern i will say
it should be a solid fill
but the color shouldn't be black because
that's going to be way too dark rather
let's just say
yeah gray
hit ok
hit apply
so now everything that is being cut
outside of the building is going to have
this kind of gray color
what about
everything that's outside of the
building that's not being cut i want it
to be
light gray right so then i will go to
the projection part of it
and i'll find patterns
generic models patterns
and here i will say for background let's
use a solid fill but let's use a super
super light
gray color hit ok
ok
apply
there we go
hit ok here
so now we have this
this graphics uh graphics settings done
for this particular view if i look at it
in my sheets i can see that it's it's
there
if i were to
add more
more walls here
right
[Music]
they don't get filled in
[Music]
what oh my god come on
come on rabbit
is that because it's a basic wall no it
shouldn't be right
right
that's super strange okay let's see why
it's not
it's not working
uh let's go to view
visibility and graphics
this this really feels like a bug but
maybe i'm wrong but
i haven't seen this happen before
at all
but i guess it's it's nice to from time
to time see
i see these things happen so let me
change the color to red
apply
it's thinking
will it crack okay it doesn't crash but
it's not filling it in
okay we will need to revisit that part
later and then figure out why the hell
is that happening
um if this happens just try closing and
opening rhino again that's probably
going to solve it oh
i know
[Music]
i'm dumb
um this wall
right here this wall
it
its height is 1.1 meters
which means it doesn't reach the section
through which we cut which means we are
actually not cutting through these walls
but right
[Music]
cancel
we're not cutting through these walls
but rather we are just looking at the
top of these walls right
uh probably in the
section one is going to be a little bit
more clear no it's not in section two
yeah there we go so in section two you
can actually see these walls here
all right so we are not cutting through
them at that height
this is why it's not
filling in but if i select them and i
change the unconnected height of them to
let's see two meters
hit apply
now they're being cut
okay so that was
can't make a perfect tutorial
um always something there's always
something wrong
okay
that's done let's jump into first floor
and see that oh crap first floor also
requires us to do exactly the same thing
as we did for the ground floor
so then the question is
is it possible to somehow save these
settings
these graphics settings and apply them
to all other floors and yes the answer
is of course yes the of course
i will just go to visibility graphics
right here
and i
will or wait no sorry sorry not
visibility graphics cancel cancel that
uh in ground floor i will go to view
templates
here
and i will say create template from
current view
and i will name this
kinda good
floor
plan
style
hit
okay it's going to save it
hit ok again and now in the first floor
i can go to view templates again
and choose apply template properties to
current view
and then i will find my kind of good
floor plan style
apply properties
and hit ok and now my first floor also
has the same
view
second floor
view templates apply
kind of good
okay
third floor three templates apply
kind of good okay
so that's done
now the question is
can we do this for a 3d view for
instance no maybe not
can we do this for
section right because section is
basically just a vertical plan right or
a plan is a horizontal section whatever
you want to call it so can we apply the
same
view
template here if i go to view templates
apply and i choose apply template
properties from view
you might not see
uh the
that our template here that's because uh
there's a filter applied which only is
looking for templates which are uh
which work with sections elevations and
whatnot
so
i will expand this and i will just say
all
and i'll then find my kind of good floor
plan style
hit apply
hit okay
still works but the problem with this
one is that it's still i still need more
to to to change more styles here because
for instance floor slabs they are not
being cut
and also i kind of want to cut through
the
through the doorway so let me move that
section as well so in the ground floor
plan i will just take the section
and i will move it
so that it cuts
there we go so that it cuts through the
the staircase and also the doorway in
the first floor
let's look at section two
no section one
there we go
so
now we are cutting through the the stair
which is not being hatched in properly
and we are cutting through the
the floor slabs which are not being
hashed in properly uh if we had a roof
that also wouldn't be hatched in
properly so we need to fix a few things
let me go to visibility and graphics
settings
find stairs
stairs there we go
cut line override
solid line
black color
weight
also five
that seems to be working for us quite
well
for patterns override
background
solid fill
black
apply
there we go our staircase is now black
and
floor slabs
ffff floors not floor slabs just floors
pattern is going to be black
and solid
and lines are going to be
solid
black
weight five apply
okay
this is what we have right nothing too
fancy but it does the trick
okay so we have that going on
and that's our section and if we take a
look at our section in here or actually
maybe we should
fill in nah nah let's not
uh so let's see where is our section
section aa there we go
here it is
all
all ready to be plotted out
um
facade
actually i kind of like the style of the
facade here
i don't really want to change anything
the only thing that i kind of want to do
is add shadows
to the facade so i will go to
my
street elevation
right here and here in the bottom i will
choose shadows to be turned on like that
and maybe i'll click on the small sun
icon send settings
and i will just mess around with the sun
so
can i just do still
still hit apply
let me change the location to
not boston
not no not not boston
definitely not boston
um
i think we have denmark there uh
copenhagen at least
will will you give me copenhagen or will
you give me malmo
yeah it doesn't give us malmo
whatever let's lie if
you can't find the city just lie we'll
just choose lighting and here we will
just change the altitude and azimuth so
perhaps i want it to be a little bit
lower so 30 degrees
apply
yeah that's that's a bit better and asim
of
115
so it eats up a little bit more
yeah i think that's that's about it or
maybe uh what if it's 45 degrees
with that seam as a move so it does that
this is hole in the shadow this is kinda
doing his thing yeah i think that's fine
i think that's fine
that's okay
and for the actual style
i want the building my building to be
kind of popping out a little bit more so
i will push
all surrounding buildings a little bit
backwards
with
a
gray color
basically so visibility and graphics
generic models
patterns uh no that's a cut pattern we
are not cutting anything
so projection surface patterns
color
light gray
solid fill
apply
there we go and maybe even
generic models lines
i will say solid line
and
kinda not not black but dark gray color
with kind of low weight so
weight of one
so
though the line work is a little bit uh
thinner and a little bit more towards uh
gray
um even more gray please
i know it doesn't really matter that
much but i really wanna
i'm gonna make it as nice as possible
yeah that's great enough okay
we have that done we have our building
popping up popping out
um and that is good
so
let me just double check street facade
looks like that that looks like that axo
actually i will not well maybe in the
axle also visibility and graphics
uh generic models lines
solid
gray
thin line
patterns up patterns
uh pattern solid
light gray
okay
apply okay
yo
did i mess mess up
generic models parents
it should work
okay
what about the cut what if i change the
cut here solid fill
[Music]
solid fill color
red
okay so apparently oh
that's my bad i i i can hear you
screaming at the at the screen uh
i am working in the sheet and not in the
actual 3d view
that's my bad as per usual oh my god
so let's do it here
[Laughter]
generic models patterns
light gray
solid fill
generic models pattern solid
color dark
gray weight very low
apply
perfect
section could be
no let's keep section as it is
just hit ok
right so that our our building kind of
pops up a bit more
okay
we have that going on
um
right so that's about it that's about it
in terms of our
our graphics
i think
it's turning out to be okay
students tend to ask me about the
lines how to change the style of the
grid lines because the style is pretty
pretty obnoxious
uh
and the the way you do it is you
download a nicer style and actually
could we
so to load in a section
um a new section markup for instance you
go to load family
and here
it's it's going to be under english
annotations by the way if if you
can't find the folder of the library
let's say you're you're in the desktop
uh it's located in this pc
c disk drive
program data which is a hidden folder if
you don't know how to
see all hidden folders you need to
actually go to
any folder that you have on your desktop
or on your computer you go to view tab
click on options you go to view tab
again in the options and you choose show
hidden files folders and drives hit
apply hit ok and then you will see the
program data folder
and here you see autodesk
uh
rvt2021 libraries finally we are here
they are really hiding it from us
it's under english
and i believe it should be under
annotations right
because where else could it be
yeah it's
yes it should be under annotations
um grid level
section section head there we go section
head and here we see different types of
section heads and all of them are
complete garbage
not garbage but uh really disgusting so
it is what it is
you're stuck with ugly section heads in
in revit unless you download one from
the internet that's that's nice
um in terms of editing the section head
itself
zoomed in to close again
[Music]
in in in case of editing the section
itself i believe um
if you select it
if you select it there we go
you can change
with that in the type
cloud tag
jesus christ that's a lot of
you know what
let's not dig too deep in into here
just have a freaking section in there
and
yeah you just have a freaking section in
there and then call it a day that's
that's fine that you don't need to
to have it too
too intense
um
right what else is there to to show you
oh that's it uh let's let's plot it out
uh let's plot everything out so you have
your sheets ready let's see
i have a few of them yeah sure save the
project always save the project by the
way
um i have a few ready here
and it's time to
print out or plot out your sheets into
pdf so i'll go to file
print
or is it export
no it's print
file print
print
or just click on this print button here
that's that works as well
where here we have all of the different
different settings uh that you can
use for for plotting out the the sheets
so first things first printer we will
choose adobe pdf or
microsoft print to pdf i think that one
works as well
anything that has the pdf word in it
should work so adobe pdf for me
kind combine multiple selected view
sheets into a single file so do we want
it in a single file yeah sure
whatever
print range
uh we will not use current view
instead we will use selected views
selected views sheets and i will click
on the select button
and i will say i want to print out this
this this this this these sheets right
not the floor plans not the structural
plans just the sheets
i'll hit okay
do you want to save these settings for
use in the future revit session sure
yeah sure
so that's going to be my set one
apparently
my the name and the location of where
i'm going to be exporting the pdf is uh
weird so i'll just be exporting it to
desktop so i'll just choose desktop hit
save
yeah perfect and the name of the file
well right now it doesn't matter because
i'm going to be messing around with it
in photoshop so that's that's okay
um
right let's see these two buttons here
properties as well as the setup so
properties if i click on that
i can see here
nothing fancy nothing special paper
source whatever layout
landscape
if i click on the advanced i can see
that the paper size is said to be letter
rather than a3
that's a nice way of hiding it let me
just see if
okay
so we don't need to go to properties
here sorry about that you just go to
settings setup
and here we can actually change it from
the
the
letter size to the proper a3 size
so we are working these sheets are
tailored for a3 its landscape format
is going to be
centered sure
and the zoom is going to be 100 so it's
not fit to page it's rather zoom
100
uh vector processing sure raster quality
high colors
color
oh yeah you can choose either color or
grayscale we'll just use color that's
fine
um
everything else is fine seems to be okay
so i'll just hit ok and i'll hit ok
again
you have chosen to print five views as
separate files
do i want to yes i do want them as
separate files because i'm going to
photoshop them so i'll hit yes
um
right let me just create a new folder
just so that it's easy for me to find
raw
pdf
pdfs
raw pdfs hit save
it's doing its magic saving it while
it's doing it i'll open up photoshop
real fast
[Music]
by now you should be able to
kind of
wait just a second uh
there revit
save
so you will need to click save for every
sheet that's not a problem um by now you
should be able to
uh to to
work with with pdfs uh
in photoshop easily
um that that's my expectation because we
have been doing doing it for the past
four
courses now or three with three or four
four
past four courses
no this is the fourth one right
anyway we've been doing it quite quite a
lot so you should be able to add
textures and change colors and and
whatnot in photoshop of your drawings
hopefully
don't show me this again close
uh so that's that so i will just be
really quick in showing you this last
bit
save that
and i think that's that's the last of it
right yes okay so let me save this file
in photoshop i will just
find my
folder with all of the pdfs
i'll just kind of drag all of them in
and just choose what which which one i
want to
work with and show you
show you how i'm going to work with it
so crop 2
not bounding box never bounding box
media box
you always when you import pdf you
choose media box so that it doesn't mess
up your a3 size
other than that it seems fine
okay
uh media box yes that's good
so it remembers at least it remembers
that's good
okay okay okay
okay
okay
so we have our section we have our
uh elevation we have our
axo floor plan floor plan so floor plans
are kind of boring i will just
close them immediately
won't photoshop anything there
um i could work here maybe
on this one
[Music]
i don't know i i like how clean it is
let's work on the elevation instead
so section also goes away sure
let me just show you how i would work on
it with uh on the elevation so
let's say i want uh
some sort of pattern here i i don't know
some some form of pattern let's say
metal or something like that i'll just
go to the interwebs
i'll go to google and i'll say
what's a cool pattern metal
metal sheet
pattern
[Music]
corrugated steel or something like that
um
perforated diamond that's that's
whatever
are there any good ones
licensable
no
yeah that's good enough right
uh i will just open it in a new window i
know it has the
watermark
this is for a tutorial so
we don't care
uh so i'll just position it
i will
cut away the part that i
need
copy paste
um so there's one unnecessary layer that
i delete
um i will say
do we multiply oops that's the wrong one
that's the actual drawing do we multiply
the
the texture yeah we do we probably do
but before we do that let me try to get
rid of the
watermark by
going to levels and
messing around with
with the levels
yeah that seems okay
that seems good enough
uh make it smaller
like that that's perfect
ctrl a ctrl c ctrl v to duplicate it
maybe ctrl t right clicking and flip
vertical to
kind of have a
much more call it
uh
a seamless connection between between
the two textures i will just merge these
two layers together merge layers
place them here
ctrl c ctrl v
again
[Music]
merge the layers again
ctrl a ctrl c ctrl v
again
but this one ctrl t and right click flip
horizontal
so that they did emerge more nicely
merge layers
now i will jump to multiply
that seems okay maybe make it a bit
smaller
that seems fine
maybe a bit bigger
yeah that's sounds
looks looks around right
i can
then select
the area in which i want them
uh ctrl
shift i to invert the selection and then
hit delete to get rid of everything else
ctrl d to
deselect
and then just
go to town and
remove
remove
that delete
remove that
delete
that gets removed
lit
also that
uh what else there we go that's the the
doorway here
that gets removed
and that gets removed
so also
also i want a
a little bit of a gradient here
right here
just to show that this is like a better
show that this is a cantilever so i'll
just
mark out where i want the gradient to be
that goes from black to white i'll
create a new layer just
drag out the gradient there
like this
i'll say
21 something like this and it kind of
you know this is without the gradient
this is with so it just gives a little
bit of a of a shadow there
um right so we have a little bit of the
corrugated steel it's not great by any
stretch of imagination
but it does the trick
and i think what we can do is we can
find
some sort of a
colored texture so
cortan
steel
corten steel texture
um
yeah sure let's let's use this one
uh
open image
oh that's that's a
pretty low resolution but we don't care
ctrl v
paste it here
i'll actually split it into parts
ctrl x ctrl v
place it here
[Music]
this one
control x control up
in this layer ctrl x ctrl v
[Music]
i don't know what i did but that's that
that works as well
like that
perhaps
[Music]
that's good enough
and then
actually can we just do that yeah we can
just do that
no one will ever know
um so this and
the bottom one i will just add
uh are you the bottom one no are you the
bottom one yes
ctrl c ctrl v
just add it there
okay so let me merge all of these
together
merge layers
ctrl t to transform them a little bit
more so that they're a little bit bigger
um let's say multiply right
so i think multiply will work and we
already did some cutting
so i'll just use the magic wand tool
with certain tolerance and just select
the cutouts
like that
ctrl shift i to invert
delete nope
uh ctrl shift i delete there we go okay
so we deleted and we are kind of
good to go with the with the carton
steel let's make it a little bit less
intense
something like that i think that that
that that's fine
um and then for the windows
i'll actually use the
[Music]
the magic wand tool to select the glass
bam
[Music]
bam
come on
ah yay
almost there there we go is that glass i
i think that's glass at least and that
is definitely glass okay
uh so we have those done and i will just
say
let's do
let's do control
do we just use gradients rather
maybe
like that and then we switch the
gradient to white and just give it
like this kind of a kind of a tug here
or maybe not
perfect white um
a little bit of of gray
look like that look like that uh
that that looks okay of course re reduce
the
the intensity of it
the opacity of it
something like this
um and i think if we just kind of
casually now select everything that's
remaining
and just
edit
fill
shift five
foreground color hit okay
[Music]
in a new fold
in a new layer
so that's shift f5 okay
[Music]
and we just move it below
the whole thing
[Music]
why is that
oh
that's my bed
so you can't do that this way huh
uh
i wanna
i want to
color the frames
so how do we color the frames this is
going to be uh
now it's turning out to be a photoshop
tutorial i want to color the frames but
i don't want to select them
individually so what i'm going to do is
i will say
okay
first of all can we just do that
not really oh or maybe we can control d
um maybe we can if i go to curtain steel
layer
and i just select all of this
right
so i selected all of this
and then
we
go to
the window layer and we
unselect holding down the alt key was it
the alt key was it control
i don't remember
control shift no alt shift
no uh how what's the shortcut for the
subtract from selection
it should be ctrl
right no it should be shift no it should
be
hold
there we go so it is the old key
i don't know why why that
didn't work out
and tolerance needs to be like a hundred
for this to work
uh it doesn't really work that well
maybe
seems to be working okay
now
so we have that we are unselecting that
oh
messed up
ah
do i really need to do it again
i know
i i i figured it out
this this this and that
and this right we select this bear with
me be patient or skip ahead
you have the possibility to skip ahead
um so i select inside of the windows and
then i turn on the drawing
and unselect
the glass but why didn't it oh yeah
that's because i need to be in the
drawing layer and then i can unselect
the glass panes
planes paints
glass
glass thingies
and it's a mess here but that's fine
so i am unselecting and now i'm i'm
selecting the shadowy bits as well
with less tolerance maybe 32 i like
tolerance of 32. it seems to work
most of the time with most of the
geometry
so like that
that good that looks good
that looks
okay
and that also looks good okay so now we
have only selected the frames for the
windows
which means we can
create a new layer
shift of five enter fill it with black
color
okay
took us a while but we we we managed we
managed to do it
um
let's change the
the intensity
so that you can see the line work
and for the door
um
for the doors both of them actually this
one still needs
oh come on just give me the
this one still needs the framing
and for some reason it chooses to do it
like that
to select it like that so let me just
for this frame i'll just do it the
old-fashioned way
with the rectangular marquee tool
there we go
almost
almost
now there we go um
is that my frames yes that that this my
frames shift f5 okay
okay we're done here
and then select
the door
somehow
that that
doesn't let me so i will be using a
marquee tool again
so the door
as well as the door here
holding down the shift key to
select the door
um
so these will
be
blue
just because i can
no i'm kidding
it's not going to be blue i'm just going
to
color it blue
and
change it to multiply
that's color burn that's not change it
to multiply change the opacity to
be
33 ish
36
ctrl u
hello ctrl u
why can't i
control u there we go ctrl u and then
change the hue until i find a nice nice
color for the doors
um what works with corten steel
yellow of course would work but that's
kind of boring
um
pink
red
maybe red
or maybe yeah let's let's just do
do it traditional peachy
okay
that is that uh let's call it uh call it
a day i i think that's that looks fine
good good enough for for a tutorial uh
control
shift
or rather control s straight up
uh to save it uh let me go to desktop
find my pdfs
find my pdfs find my pdfs oh my god
where are they
car project
raw pdfs goddammit raw pdfs change this
to a pdf photoshop pdf format and then
find my street facade there we go
i can turn off layers right now don't
need them hit save
do you want to replace it yes
okay
uh high quality print
preserve photoshop editing capabilities
i usually have this turned off hit save
pdf
oh yeah of course
i have it opened right here and also i
have it opened right here
so let me close it here and try to save
it again oh just
yikes um
[Music]
control s
pdf
pdf
uh
street facade
no layers don't need that save yes
replace it hit ok
let's save pdf
okay this time it worked
so now
once i
close this
and turn this off i can see that my
street facade here is
is nice
and crispy so
if you have adobe acrobat pro version
you can select all of your pdfs right
click them
choose
combine pdfs in acrobat
then you just move them around
so that's going to be the title page and
then we have uh floor plans and then
um
poor plants
yeah sure i that this works or maybe
section goes in here
it goes up
up until there
um
we
click on combine why is this so big
we click on combine
it does its magic
creates a binder we can we take a closer
look at it
first second third fourth fifth page
for me
i hit file
save as
um we go to i'll just save it to desktop
and this is where i go
this is important you guys a a d a
15
l
f
i forgot my last name
here they kiss
save
that's it you're done right you have
your
uh your pdfs
where is it
where is it there we go
there it is you have your pdf saved
right
um and then you just uploaded it to
the school server
uh i already did a tutorial on how to do
it before so i will not be repeating
that
but or maybe maybe i should okay so i
will repeat that so
if you're in the school
then you
can
let me just mimic me being in the school
without being in the school
um ma'am
bam
ma'am just a second
so in the school
uh you just go to
temp
folder
unprotected
and you
aad 15
hand in
beautiful writing
capital h capital h hendon
there we go ada 15 handen
open up that folder
drag and drop or drag and drop not the
syllabus
the
your your file in here
that's it you've passed the course right
if you don't have access if you can't
get into the school
remember that there is a remote desktop
option
right
all of the
information
is in the on the course website under uh
useful resources so there is a remote
desktop version where you can
log into the school's computer from your
browser
and just send an email to yourself with
the file and load it in
load it in through the remote remote
desktop
that that should be
pretty simple to do as well so there's
no need for us to do a separate server
or a separate folder
uh you just do it that way either one of
the ways works
alternatively you can always just
create a vpn connection and that that's
going to work as well
okay
i will leave you to it
get to work
and
i hope to see some really nice
narrow houses from you